WELL COULD AFTER EVERYONE.
I'M ASH KALRA COLORISM A MEMBER FROM
SAN JOSE A DISTRICT TWENTY SEVEN
I'M VERY HONORED TO BE THE CHAIR
OF THE ASSEMBLY AGING AND LONG
TERM CARE COMMITTEE.
AND ALSO HONORED TO HAVE WITH ME
ABOUT MY COLLEAGUES WERE
KAMLAGER-DOVE [INAUDIBLE]
I'M AND I JUST WANTED.
EVERYONE THAT'S HERE --
MANY OF YOU.
I HAVE GOTTEN TO KNOW PRETTY
WELL.
OVER THE LAST SAID YEAR AND A
HALF OR SO SINCE THE OF MINE
ROLE.
WAS ESTABLISHED WITH THE
COMMUNITY.
I AND I LOOK FORWARD TO MEETING
MORE OF YEAH I BECAUSE AND PART
OF THE REASON WHY I LIKE DOING
THESE.
INFORMATION HEARINGS AROUND THE
STATE IS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO REALLY CREATE NETWORK.
OF ACTIVISTS AND ADVOCATES
AROUND THE STATE AND I THINK
THAT BASED UPON WHAT WE'VE SEEN
HAPPEN OVER THE PAST YEAR
LEGISLATIVELY THROUGH THE BUDGET.
I THINK OUR COLLECTIVE WORK
TOGETHER IS WORKING OF WE'RE
SEEING THINGS GETTING DONE WE'RE
SEEING.
ARMED WHO UP BUDGET REFLECTING
SOME OF THE NEEDS SHOW AND ALL
THE NEEDS OF SOME OF THE NEEDS.
THAT TERM THAT WE HAVE IN TERMS
OF CARING FOR AGING THE LONG
TERM CARE.
COMMUNITIES.
ARE AND WE'RE ALSO SEEING.
SOME MOMENTUM BEING BUILT I IN
TERMS OF OUR ABILITY.
TO I AND I THINK THAT --
AS MANY OF YOU OF OUR PART OF
OUR WERE ACT THE INFORMATION
HEARINGS WE HAD LAST YEAR.
OF THROUGHOUT THE STATE A IN
SALAS A IN LOS ANGELES AND SAN
DIEGO.
OF SAW DURING THE COURSE OF THIS
YEAR MUCH OF WHAT WE LEARNED OR
DISCUSSED DURING THOSE HEARINGS
WERE ACTUALLY IMPROVED OVER
ACTUALLY PUSH FORWARD AS
LEGISLATION.
AND HAVE EITHER BEEN IMPLEMENTED
GRANTED IN THE BUDGET OR ARE.
STILL GOING TO LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE HOPE WILL HAVE A
POSITIVE OUTCOME AYE AND THERE
ARE PLENTY OF OTHER THINGS --
THERE'S PLENTY MORE TO DO ON THE
CHECKLIST TO WORK THAT WE NEED
TO GET DONE BUT I FOUND THE
HEARINGS BE VERY PRODUCTIVE AND
THAT'S WHY I'M VERY EXCITED. TO
BE HERE TODAY ARM OF THE TO
DISCUSS A FURTHER BUT WE NEED TO
DEAL.
OF AND I THINK THAT THE THE
CALIFORNIA TASK FORCE ON FAMILY
CARE GIVING.
A REPORT HUB CERTAINLY BRINGS UP
A LOT OF ISSUES THAT CONTINUE TO
COME UP WE TALK ABOUT.
ISSUES OF CARING FOR OUR ELDERLY
CARING FOR PEOPLE DISABILITIES
AND IN PARTICULAR THE STRESS OF
PUTS ON CAREGIVERS AND WHAT WE
NEED TO DO.
ADMITTED TO ADDRESS THAT IN AN
APPROPRIATE WAY.
I WANNA THANK YOU S. USC LEONARD
DAVIS SCHOOL GERONTOLOGY UP FOR
HOSTING THE COMMITTEE HEARING
AND FOR THEIR WORK.
ON THIS REPORT US OR THE ONE
THING A EUROPEAN ARE STONE
FOUNDATION FOR FUNDING.
THIS WHERE THE PROJECT AND I'M
VERY EXCITED TO HEAR.
AND MORE SIGNIFICANTLY WHAT
COMES AFTER THIS BECAUSE I DO
THINK THERE'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO LEARN.
I'M FROM THIS REPORT FROM THE
THOUGHTS OF OUR EXPERTS I'M AND
TO MOVE FORWARD ON WITH.
TOPPLED LEGISLATION OF PAPA A
COUPLE BUDGET WITH THE NEW
GOVERNOR COMING AND THAT WILL
HELP US.
CONTINUE TO GIVE IT TO CARE FOR
OUR CARE GIVERS ALBERT SHOULD WE
KNOW RIGHT NOW IS NOT HAPPENING
QUITE ENOUGH WE KNOW OUR
CAREGIVERS ARE STRUGGLING.
AND SO WITH THAT BEFORE I WE
MOVE FORWARD I CERTAINLY WANT TO
GIVE A MY COLLEAGUE AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO SAY A FEW WORDS
LIKE TO HAVE A VERY BRIEF
INTRODUCTION AND SO BUT I'M VERY
EXCITED THAT AND EARLIER THIS
YEAR.
AS AMERICANS TO REMEMBER SYDNEY
A KAMLAGER-DOVE OF A WAS.
ELECTED AND AND SOON AFTER SWORN
AND A BECAUSE OF THE NEWEST
MEMBER OF THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
I HAVE BOUGHT THAT TIME AT LEAST
AND ABOUT A COUPLE OF YOU KNOW
THOSE TRANSITION THIS YEAR BUT
IT'S BEEN GOOD BECAUSE YOU'VE
GOT FOLKS LIKE SYDNEY.
AYE INTO POSITIVE DISSIDENT
AGAIN THE SECOND HALF WHERE
AMERICAN WOMAN ELECTED TO THE
LOS ANGELES BEAUTY COLLEGE
DISTRICT.
AND MOST RECENTLY SHE WAS OF THE
DISTRICT DIRECTORS WHO ARE
WONDERFUL SENATOR HOLLY MITCHELL
AND AND A VERY BRIEF TIME THAT --
SYDNEY IS BEEN WITH US
LEGISLATORS ALREADY MAKING HER
IMPACT FELT AND ACTUALLY.
ALMOST RIGHT AWAY A UPON JOINING
US INDICATOR INTERESTS IN TERMS
OF ISSUES REGARDING AGING LONG
TERM CARE SENIORS.
AND SO I WAS VERY EXCITED TO
HAVE REJOINED THE AND VERY
EXCITED TO HOLD THIS HEARING
HERE LOS ANGELES CLOSER DISTRICT
BUDS OF THE CERTAINLY --
DATA OF FELLOW COMMITTEE MEMBER
THAT IS SO COMMITTED I THINK
IT'S GONNA BE A BENEFIT ALL OF
US OF A CITY.
WELL THANK YOU CHAIR --
I WANNA.
OFFICIALLY THANK MY COLLEAGUE
AND THE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE
ARCH KALRA FOR YOUR COMMITMENT --
TO FURTHERING THIS KIND OF
DOLLARS DIALOGUE ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE WHILE I CAN'T OUT
WELCOME YOU TO THE FIFTY FOURTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT I CAN WELCOME
YOU TO MY ALMA MATER I ACTUALLY
TOOK CLASSES IN THIS VERY
AUDITORIUM.
AND SO WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
GERONTOLOGY I'M HAVE A LITTLE
FLASHBACKS OF MY OWN --
WE SPEND SO MUCH TIME TALKING
ABOUT.
HOW WE'RE GOING TO RELATE TO
MILLENNIALS?
BUT I THINK IT'S EQUALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS A NOT FORGET.
HOW WE INTERACT WITH OUR ELDER
COMMUNITIES?
AND REALLY HOW WE WORK TO FORAGE
THE BRIDGES ON THE GAPS BETWEEN
THE GENERATIONS BECAUSE
ULTIMATELY IT'S ALWAYS ONE
GENERATION TAKING CARE OF
ANOTHER AS IT PREPARES TO STEP
INTO.
THOSE SPACES IN THOSE SHOES AND
SO RATHER THAN CREATING
GENERATIONAL SILOS YOU KNOW HOW
DO WE CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT THE
ISSUES THAT CHALLENGE.
ARM ALL OF OUR GENERATIONS BUT
SPECIFICALLY OUR ELDER
COMMUNITIES I'M AND THE
CAREGIVERS WHO ARE GENERALLY.
YOU KNOW THEIR CHILDREN AND BABY
BOOMERS --
YOU KNOW AS WE CONTINUE TO
EVOLVE AS A SOCIETY AND A
COMMUNITIES SO THAT'S WHY THESE
KINDS OF DIALOGUES ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT.
YOU KNOW MY GRANDMOTHER PASSED
AWAY IN APRIL ACTUALLY THE NIGHT
BEFORE -- I
WAS ELECTED AND MY MOTHER.
SPENT HER.
FINAL YEARS AS A PRIMARY
CAREGIVER FROM MY GRANDMOTHER.
IN TALKING ABOUT THE CHALLENGES
THAT CARE GIVERS SPACE
[INAUDIBLE]
STRESSES THE FINANCES THIS
NOTION THAT YOU HAVE TO DEPLETE
EVERYTHING IN ORDER TO GET THE
KIND OF SUB FUNDING AND SUPPORT
THAT YOU KNOW YOUR PARENT OR
HONOR SISTER WHO EVER.
DESERVES.
AND WHAT HOW THAT IMPACTS A
FAMILY HOW THAT IMPACTS THE
COMMUNITY AND ULTIMATELY.
HOW WE CAN DO BETTER?
AND SO WOULD CERTAINLY NOT ABOUT
STRESSING OUT ONE PERSON.
OR SACRIFICING ONE PERSON. FOR
THE BENEFIT OF ANOTHER IS
FIGURING OUT HOW TO RAISE THE
TIED FOR ALL OF THE BOAT SO THAT
CARE GIVERS AND THOSE THAT THEY
ARE CARING FOR FEEL SAFE.
AND FEEL LIKE THEY'RE BEING
THOUGHT OF IN THE POLICIES IN IN
THE FUNDING DECISIONS THAT
COUNTIES THAT STATES IN THAT
LOCAL COMMUNITIES MAKE ARM AND I
THINK THAT'S WHY THIS COMMITTEE
IN THIS CONVERSATION IS SO
IMPORTANT AND I THINK THE PANEL.
FOR THE EXPERTISE AND FOR THE
INFORMATION THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
SHARE.
AND LASTLY I THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT THAT WHEN WE HAVE
THESE CONVERSATIONS WERE REALLY
TALKING ABOUT THE CULTURAL
SENSITIVITIES THAT COME WITH THE
AGING PROCESS IF IT'S REYES IF
IT'S GENDER IF IT'S ETHNICITY IF
IT'S RELIGION.
IF IT SEXUAL ORIENTATION WE HAVE
FOLKS THAT ARE AGING WHO ARE AS
DIVERSE AS WE ARE AS OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE IN SO IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HOW WE'RE FUNDING IN
CARRYING IN KEEPING THIS
COMMUNITY SAFE.
AS IT IS THAT WE'RE RECOGNIZING
THE DIVERSE CITY ARM AND THE
CULTURAL SENSITIVITY THAT WE
SHOULD BE USING AS A LANDS WHEN
WE ARE DEALING WITH OUR CARE
GIVER AND OUR ELDER COMMUNITIES
SO I'M EXCITED ABOUT THE
INFORMATION THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR AND THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER
CHAIR.
THANK YOU SAME MEMBER I THINK A
BECAUSE YOU I'M SO EXCITED TO
HAVE -- OR
MY MY COLLEAGUES ON BOARD OF
THESE REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUES
NOT JUST BECAUSE OF A PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE PREVENT BUT ALSO HER
ELOQUENCE AND DETERMINATION.
AND MAKING SURE WE DO EVERYTHING
THAT WE CAN --
CONTINUE. TO INCREASE RESOURCES
OF MOBERG CAREGIVERS BUT ALSO TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE AUDIO OF A
QUALITY OF LIFE THAT.
ARE ELDERLY AND AND PEOPLE
DISABILITIES CERTAINLY DESERVE.
AND SO OFTEN WITH THAT THAT'S A
GOOD MOVE ON AND WHAT I'M GONNA
DO RIGHT NOW IS GIVE A QUICK A
COUPLE MINUTES A ONE MINUTE OR
SO.
ADDED DISCUSS WHY WE'RE HERE
WHICH IS ACR THIRTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BROWN OUT HE'S
GONNA HAVE FROM IN A MOMENT.
OF WHICH ESTABLISHED THE
CALIFORNIA TASK FORCE ON FAMILY
CAREGIVING TO EXAMINE ISSUES
RELATIVE TO THE CHALLENGES FACED
BY FAMILY CAREGIVERS AND
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE.
CAREGIVER SUPPORT.
OTHERS TASK FORCE WAS REQUIRED
TO SUBMIT AN INTERIM REPORT
LEGISLATURE NO LATER THAN
JANUARY.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND A
FINAL REPORT NO LATER THAN JULY.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE PURPOSE OF
THIS HEARING AS WITH THE TASK
FORCE PRESENT REPORT AND THEIR
FINDINGS LAWS OUR POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND ALL STAKEHOLDERS RESPOND AND
THEN SUBSEQUENT TO THAT OF THE
WILL HAVE CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT
IN THE MONTHS AHEAD ANZIO
CERTAIN THE MEMBERS THE
LEGISLATURE TO SEE.
OF AS IT APPLIES TO SOME OF THE
REALLY IMPORTANT RECOMMENDATIONS
WHAT WE CAN DO TO TRY TO MOVE
SOME OF THEM FORWARD.
A AND SO WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE A MY PREDECESSOR AS
CHAIR OF THE AGING A LONG TERM
CARE COMMITTEE AND I FEEL VERY
FORTUNATE BECAUSE IT'S NOT A
MATTER OF HER HANGING THE BATON
TO ME.
REALLY WERE BOTH RUNNING WITH
THE BATON AND I THINK THAT WHEN
YOU WHEN YOU'RE BUILDING A TEAM.
OF FOLKS I REALLY CARE ABOUT
THESE ISSUES [INAUDIBLE]
AND I'M SUBSEQUENT TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BROWN'S I'M PUTTING
FORWARD ACR THIRTY EIGHT SO NOW
WE CAN ALL BENEFIT FROM THE
INFORMATION FROM THE REPORT AND
THAT WE CAN ALL MOVE THE BALL
FLOORS WITH THAT AS A MEMBER ASH
A BROWN SHOW BROWN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIRMAN KALRA.
I'M SORRY THAT I THEN GET AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE WITH YOU.
AND A ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF THE
PEOPLE THINK [INAUDIBLE]
OUR BUT I THANK YOU THANK YOU
BOTH FOR RUNNING WITH THE
THOUGHT THAT WAS A PART OF MY
PREPARED NOTES HOW ABOUT THAT.
HE OUR THIRTY EIGHT THE
CALIFORNIA TASK FORCE ON FAMILY
CARE GIVING.
BEGAN OF THE BILL.
IT WAS AB.
SEVENTEEN FORTY FOUR THAT BILL
WAS PASSED BY BOTH HOUSES WITH
NO NO VOTES.
BUT IT WAS VETO.
AND THE MESSAGE WAS THAT IT
WASN'T NECESSARY.
HOWEVER PRESIDENT HAD ALREADY
BEEN SET BY MR MURPHY I'M ONLY.
IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WHEN HE
AUTHORED THE ARM RESOLUTION ON
FIBROMYALGIA.
BOTH RESOLUTIONS WERE OF
STATEWIDE IMPORTANCE.
AS THE FORMER CHAIR OF AGING AND
LONG TERM CARE.
IT WAS MY HONOR THE FIGHT FOR
SENIORS.
AND OUR ISSUES.
AS THE CARE GIVER MYSELF FOR
MOST OF MY LIFE I UNDERSTAND
FIRST HAND.
ISSUES CONFRONTING FAMILY
CAREGIVERS.
AND I MADE IT A TOP PRIORITY.
I KNEW MUCH OF THE WORK.
AND MUCH MORE WORK HAD TO BE
DONE IN THIS AREA.
UNPAID CAREGIVERS ARE THE FOR
GOTTEN OFF WORK FORCE OF THE
LONG TERM CARE SYSTEM.
WE PROVIDE SOME FORTY SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
IN FLAVOR [INAUDIBLE]
FREE LABOR.
SO WHEN A A RP PROPOSED THE IDEA.
I KNEW THE TIME WAS RIGHT.
WITH PARTNERS LIKE ART STONE THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
THE ALZHEIMER'S THAT THE
ASSOCIATION.
THE PROPOSAL WAS ON TARGET
[INAUDIBLE]
FEED.
THE FUNDING WAS SECURED AND IT
DIDN'T COST THE STATE BUDGET
UNDYING.
THIS WILL THE PUBLIC PRIVATELY
FUNDED OPERATION.
THE TASK FORCE WAS TO EXAMINE
ISSUES FACED BY CAREGIVERS THEY
WERE TO REVIEW EXISTING THE
EXISTING NETWORKS OF SERVICES.
AND SUPPORTS AVAILABLE TO
CAREGIVERS.
BEFORE THEY BEGAN THEIR WORK.
THERE WAS NO.
THERE WAS NO COMPLETE INVENTORY
OF CARE GIVING PROGRAMS
AVAILABLE. TO US SUCCESSFULLY
ADDRESS THE SURGING POPULATION.
OF OLDER ADULTS WHO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT NEEDS FOR LONG TERM
CARE SERVICES AND SUPPORTS.
THIS TASK FORCE WILL NOW MAKE
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
I'M SO HAPPY TO BE WITH THIS
GROUP OF WOMEN AND MEN.
WHO WERE GOING TO HELP TAKE THIS
TO ANOTHER LEVEL? TO HELP SO
MANY FAMILIES.
THANK YOU EACH MEMBER OF THE
TASK FORCE.
UFC LEONARD DAVID SCHOOL OF
GERONTOLOGY.
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
DR DONNA BITTEN.
STAFF INCLUDING BARRY BREWER.
AND A SPECIAL THANK YOU. TO YOUR
CHAMPION.
RETIRING SANDY FITZPATRICK.
AND TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASH KALRA.
AND NOW TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER DELVE.
I CAN'T THANK YOU ENOUGH FOR
YOUR WORKERS TO CONTINUE
SOMETHING THAT I HOLD SO DEAR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M AGAIN OF
THANK YOU FOR REALLY.
BEING OF THE LEADER AND CHAMPION
ON THIS WE WOULDN'T BE HERE IF
WAS NOT FOR USE WITH THANK YOU A
AND WE'RE VERY FORTUNATE TO HAVE
SOME EXTRAORDINARY PANELISTS ON
THE EXPERTISE.
OF MANY OF THE UPPER TASK FORCE
MEMBERS AND AND SPEAKING OF
WHICH THE CHAIR.
OF OUR A CALIFORNIA TASK WASN'T
FAMILY CAREGIVING DR DONNA
BENTON --
AND I'M GONNA.
MISS OUT WHAT IS THE NAME OF
FOUR OF YOU THAN YOU GUYS GO
DOWN THE LINE AND AND AND MAKE
YOUR COMMENTS.
OF ON THE ON THE REPORT I'M
DONNA BENTON WAS A RESEARCH
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OF
GERONTOLOGY.
AND AS I MENTIONED CHAIR OF THE
TASK FORCE OF THE NEXT TO HER IS
A SANDY FITZPATRICK SECTOR
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION.
ON AGING AND CULTURE OF THE TASK
FORCE.
A BUT AND THEN E. L. A DIRECTOR
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION AND
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA TASK
FORCE ON FAMILY CAREGIVING AND
THEN FINDING A DOCTOR.
KATHLEEN WILBUR A MERRY.
FOR OF PROFESSOR OF GERONTOLOGY
HERE AT USC SO YOU CAN WE HAVE
SOME EXTRAORDINARY FOLKS HERE
THEY'RE GONNA.
GET THEIR IMPRESSIONS
REFLECTIONS OF ALLAH AND AND
SOME OF THE DETAILS FROM THIS
TASK FORCE WHERE.
A DOCTOR BENTON.
GET OUT OF THAT UP HERE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND IT'S AN HONOR
TO BE HERE TODAY.
I'M I'M JUST GOING TO START WITH
BACKGROUND AND A FEW OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEN SANDY
AND I WOULD WOULD ATTACK TEAM
GENERALLY.
SO SHE'S GOING TO DO SOME MORE
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS AND SO
THAT'S HOW WE'RE GONNA START.
SO LET ME JUST PAINT A PICTURE.
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION FAMILY CAREGIVERS I
DON'T KNOW WHO'S GOING TO BE
DOING THIS LYFT.
OKAY SO.
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION FAMILY CAREGIVERS.
AND OF THAT 60% OF THESE
CAREGIVERS ARE WOMEN.
BUT REMEMBER THAT'S 40% WHO ARE
MEN [INAUDIBLE]
ON AVERAGE OUR CAREGIVERS ARE
ABOUT FORTY NINE YEARS OLD.
STILL IN THE WORK FORCE AND
ABOUT ONE IN [INAUDIBLE]
FOUR FEELS. 56% OF THESE
CAREGIVERS ARE EMPLOYED AND ONE
IN FOUR OF THE PEOPLE THAT
THEY'RE CARRYING.
FOR HAVE DEMENTIA.
AND THE AVERAGE AMOUNT OF TIME
PEOPLE STAY IN THIS ROLE IS
ABOUT FOUR YEARS.
SO FOR CALIFORNIA.
WHEN YOU ADD UP AND YOU LOOK AT
THE CONTRIBUTION THE OF THE
INFORMAL FAMILY CAREGIVER WE
HAVE ABOUT FIFTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS?
BEING ADDED TO OUR ECONOMY.
EVERY YEAR AND THAT'S MORE THAN
WHAT IS IN MEDI CAL IN TERMS OF
ECONOMIC VALUE FOR THE CAREGIVER.
SO WHAT CHALLENGES DO YOU FACE
SOME PEOPLE ARE REALLY MENTION
IT BECAUSE YOU KNOW FROM YOUR
OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE.
THAT THERE ARE HEALTH IMPACTS
FOR FAMILY CAREGIVERS.
OF WHERE WE CAN THEY GET
MUSCULAR DISEASE THAT IS THEY
HAVE CARDIOVASCULAR PROBLEMS ONE
OF THE OF PREVAILING THINGS THAT
WE SEE A LOT IS DEPRESSION AMONG
OUR CAREGIVERS.
CLINICAL DEPRESSION AND HIGH
SYMPTOMS OF DEPRESSION WHICH
REALLY LOWERS YOUR ENERGY AND
THINKING ABILITY.
I ALSO HAVE A IN SOME
POPULATIONS RESEARCHES EVEN
POINTED OUT THAT THERE'S A
HIGHER MORTALITY RATE FOR FAMILY
CAREGIVERS ARE CARING FOR
SOMEONE WITH DEMENTIA
PARTICULARLY MALE CARE GIVERS.
THE FISCAL IMPACT OF CAREGIVING
IS THERE IS A HIGH OUT OF POCKET
COST IN GENERAL AND THAT'S WHERE
THINGS THAT ARE NOT COVERED.
BY OTHER INSURANCE COMPANIES WE
HAVE A LOT OF NEGATIVE IMPACTS
ON EMPLOYMENT.
OF THE SIDES ABSENTEEISM WE HAVE
A LOT OF PRESS ANTI ISM SO FOR
OUR EMPLOYERS THEY'RE LOOKING AT
FOURTH THAT SOMETIMES IS THERE
BUT THEY'RE NOT ALWAYS PRESENT.
WE ALSO HAVE REDUCE SAVINGS
OPPORTUNITIES.
UP FOR ALL OF THE CAREGIVERS
THAT ARE THERE SO THAT IN THE
LONG RUN YOU'RE LOOKING AT IN
THE IMPACT DOWN THE LINE ON
THEIR OWN RETIREMENT ABILITIES.
AND WE HAVE AN INCREASED RISK OF
POVERTY BECAUSE MANY TIMES THE
CARE GIVER MIGHT --
BE LIVING WITH THE OLDER ADULT
ARE WITH THE FAMILY RELATIVE AND
THEN WHEN THE RELATIVE PASSES
AWAY AND THEY DON'T HAVE
ANYWHERE TO GO AND THEY CAN END
UP EVEN HOMELESS.
AND WE HAVE SEEN THAT WITH THEIR
CAREGIVERS [INAUDIBLE]
SO.
LET ME TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT WE DID OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS BESIDES EAT VERY GOOD
LUNCHES AND HER.
ALMOST WITH XENA YEAH.
AND THERE'S A LOT WE ALSO HAD WE
ACTUALLY HAD A PROCESS OF DOING
THINGS.
I WAS SO WE STARTED WITH
PRIORITY AREAS THAT WHERE I AM
PRESENTED IN OUR INTERIM REPORT
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND SO WHAT
WE DID IS WE LOOKED AT AN
INTEGRATED APPROACH.
TO CARE MANAGEMENT.
AND WE REVIEWED INFORMATION
ABOUT THE COMPREHENSIVE ARRAY A
CONTINUUM OF SERVICES THERE ARE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE'D LOOK AT CARE GIVER
COMPENSATION IN THAT REPORT AND
THE DATA ON OUR CARE GIVERS AND
SERVICES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
ALONG WITH EDUCATION AND
AFFORDABILITY AND ACCESS TO
SERVICES.
SO OUR FIRST REPORT REALLY
TRIBUTE OF VERY GOOD INVENTORY
AND TRY TO FIND OUT YOU KNOW
KIND OF WHAT COULD WE DO TOWARDS
DEVELOPING OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
WE REVIEWED ALL OF THOSE THINGS.
WE'VE THEN I'M USED A VERY
RESEARCH DRIVEN BECAUSE GUESS
WHAT WE'RE IN A RESEARCH
INSTITUTION.
AND NOT SURPRISINGLY WE REALLY
WANTED TO UNDERSTAND THINGS BY
DOING SURVEYS LOOKING AT THE
RESEARCH AND SO WE DID A REAL
COMPILATION OF WHAT OTHER STATE
TASK FORCE.
THROUGHOUT THE NATION.
OF WHAT THEY ARE AND THERE'S A
WEBSITE WHERE YOU CAN GO AND SEE
WHAT OTHER STATES HAVE BEEN
DOING IN TERMS OF TASK FORCE WE
DID A SURVEY OF AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
FINDING OUT HOW THEY ARE WORKING
WITH --
CURRENTLY WITH CAREGIVERS AND
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE BEST
PRACTICES THAT ARE SUGGESTED AND
WE DID LOOK AT THE BEST
PRACTICES AND POLICIES.
THERE ARE WITHIN CALIFORNIA BUT
ALSO ACROSS THE NATION SO THAT
WE COULD REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT
DO WE WANT TO INNOVATE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WE ARE
GENERALLY THE INNOVATIVE STATE.
AND WE WANT TO CONTINUE.
SO.
THE VALUES AND THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT -- WE
FELT THAT THIS IS AS WE DID OUR
TASK FORCE WE HAD CERTAIN VALUES
THAT WE ARE GOING TO GO
THROUGHOUT ALL OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS SO EVEN IF YOU
DON'T HEAR THESE WORDS.
THESE ARE ALWAYS PART OF OUR
UNDERSTANDING IN VALUES THAT WE
FEEL SHOULD BE PART OF ANY
RECOMMENDATION FIRST OF ALL WE
SUPPORTIVE VERY DIVERSE AND WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S A VERY
DIVERSE CARE GIVER NEEDS.
AND WE TAKE NEED TO BE INCLUDING
CULTURAL AWARENESS CULTURAL
COMPETENCY AND SENSITIVITY IN
ALL OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS IN
FUTURE LEGISLATION.
WE WANT TO EVERYTHING TO BE
PERSON AND FAMILY CENTERED AND I
THINK THAT ADDRESSES YOUR ISSUE
ACROSS GENERATIONS TO THAT YOU
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE FULL FAMILY.
WE WANT THE OTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS AND ANY FUTURE
LEGISLATION TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE HAS TO BE A WORK LIFE
BALANCE IF YOU LOOK AT THE
AVERAGE AGE.
THESE ARE STILL WORKING AND
PEOPLE AND SO THE CAREGIVERS ARE
GENERALLY WORKING AT BUT YOU
HAVE TO HAVE THAT WORK LIFE
BALANCE.
AND WE WANT CHOICE AND OPTIONS
FOR CAREGIVERS CARE GIVER DOWN
IS SOMETHING THAT SOMETIMES
YOU'RE.
A BECOME A CAREGIVER BECAUSE SO
MUCH IS TAG YOU'RE IT --
GENERALLY IT COMES FROM THE
HEART BUT YOU SHOULD ALSO HAVE
THE OPTION OF SAYING.
MAYBE I'M NOT THE BEST PERSON.
TO SO.
GIVEN THOSE ARE I USE THAT WE
WANT TO HAVE ACROSS ALL OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND PLEASE
REMEMBER THIS FOR FUTURE
LEGISLATION.
OF I'M GONNA GO OVER SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS SO THE FIRST
RECOMMENDATION AT THEIR NOT IN
ANY PARTICULAR ORDER.
I'VE DISCOVERED THAT AND HIS
OLDEST CFO'S IF IT PLEASE DON'T
TAKE THIS LIKE ALL THAT'S NUMBER.
ONE OKAY SO THEY'RE NOT IN ANY
ORDER BUT OUR FIRST THING WAS TO
LOOK AT OF OUR FIRST
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE TASK
FORCE CAME OUT TO SUPPORT THE
FINANCIAL WELL BEING.
OF FAMILY CAREGIVERS.
AND LIMIT THE EXTENT TO WHICH
THIS ROLE CONTRIBUTES TO AN
INCREASED RISK OF POVERTY.
AND LONG TERM FINANCIAL
INSECURITY.
SO HOW MIGHT YOU GO ABOUT DOING
THAT IS A LEGISLATOR
[INAUDIBLE]
WELL. ONE THING WE FELT AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE LITTLE PICTURE
ON THE SIDE OF THE NEXT SLIDE.
A YES VOTE YOU MAY NOT BE ABLE
THAT'S FUZZY BUT YOU HAVE THIS
IN YOUR PACKET.
IS JUST FOR COLOR [INAUDIBLE]
BOB.
SO HOW CAN YOU GO ABOUT ME OF
MAKING THAT RECOMMENDATION TO
REALITY WE HAD SOME SUGGESTIONS
WOULD BE A TAX CREDIT. FOR THE
HIGH OUT OF POCKET COST OF CARE
GIVERS IN SO SOME WAY LOOKING AT
THAT.
PERHAPS IT COULD BE A STIPEND OR
SIMILAR PROGRAM TO SUPPORT CARE
GIVERS WITH THE COST OF
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES.
AND THIRDLY AND THEIR MANY MORE
THEY CAN GO FOR BUT THESE ARE
LIKE OUR TOP THREE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND BUILD ON OUR FAMILY MEDICAL
LEAVE ACT AND PAID FAMILY LEAVE
LAWS THAT WE HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO THAT WE CAN REALLY
AND ONE WAY IS JUST.
VERY SIMPLY WORKING WITH
INCREASING AWARENESS OF THESE
EXISTING PROGRAMS OF AND SO
CLOSER.
OUR FIRST LETTERS OF
RECOMMENDATIONS NOW SOME OF THE
THINGS PARTICULARLY FOR THIS
LAST OF THE OF PAID FAMILY LEAVE
LAWS WE JUST WANT TO POINT OUT.
THAT THERE ARE CHALLENGES WITH
THE CURRENT LEAVE LAWS WHERE WE
HAVE ABOUT 40% OF WORKERS WHO
ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR LEAVE LAW
SO WE CAN LOOK AT THAT
LEGISLATIVELY.
AND WE DO KNOW THAT THERE'S A
VERY HIGH LACK OF AWARENESS
AMONG HR PROFESSIONALS AND
EMPLOYERS.
ABOUT THE LEAVE LAWS SO THAT WE
HAVE A ONLY ABOUT 10% OF THE
CURRENT CLAIMS ARE BEING USED BY
PAID FAMILY CAREGIVERS WHERE THE
BULK OF THE CLAIMS FOR OF PAID
FAMILY LEAVE.
ARE AROUND MATERNITY LEAVE.
AND WE KNOW THAT THEIR MORE CARE
GIVERS AND THAT 10% REFLECTS WHO
ARE WORKING.
THE NEXT RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
TASK FORCE IS TO MODERNIZE AND
STANDARDIZE CARE GIVER
ASSESSMENTS ACROSS THE STATE. TO
SUPPORT INDIVIDUALIZATION OF
SERVICES.
REDUCE SERVICE FRAGMENTATION AND
INCREASED KNOWLEDGE OF WHO AMONG
CARE GIVERS.
I IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA USE
OUR SKIRTS SERVICES.
SO WITH THIS RECOMMENDATION WHAT
WE REALLY WANT TO EMPHASIZE HERE
IS THAT THAT INDIVIDUALIZATION
BECAUSE IF YOU'VE MET ONE
CAREGIVER YOU HAVE MET ONE
CAREGIVER.
AND SO YOU REALLY DO HAVE TO
HAVE A SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS FOR
THAT.
HOW CAN WE GO ABOUT THIS
LEGISLATIVELY WELL SOME OF THE
SUGGESTIONS WE WOULD MAKE WOULD
BE TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT A
STANDARDIZED ASSESSMENT?
TO OF THEY COULD BE USED ACROSS
THE STATE INCREASED FUNDING FOR
ANY TYPE OF CARE GIVER
ASSESSMENT USUALLY THE
ASSESSMENT PIECE MAY NOT EVEN BE
PAID FOR WITH THE END.
OF A SYSTEM.
WE COULD COLLECT REPRESENTATIVE
SURVEY DATA ON CARE GIVERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE CAN REMOVE BARRIERS
ACROSS AGENCIES THAT INHIBITS
SAFE RETURN OF PEOPLE WITH AN
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY OR
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT WHICH
ALLOWS THE CARE GIVER THE KID
THEY FAMILY.
TO FIND THAT PERSON AND AND
CONTINUE THEIR CARE EASIER.
THE LAST RECOMMENDATION THAT
I'LL BE ON PRESENTING AND THEN
I'M GONNA TURN IT OVER TO SANDY.
IS THAT WE WOULD LIKE WE FEEL
THAT THERE SHOULD BE A WAY TO
CREATE A STATEWIDE ADVISORY
COUNCIL.
ON MATTERS AFFECTING FAMILY
CAREGIVERS.
THAT PROVIDES ADVICE ON
INTEGRATING CAREGIVER ISSUES
ACROSS THE STATE.
DEPARTMENT'S SERVICES.
INITIATIVES AND PROGRAMS AND
PROVIDE POLICY EXPERTISE TO THE
LEGISLATOR.
SO I LEGISLATION SO THAT MONEY
IS.
AS THEIR WAY FOR US TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE A REAL FOCUS.
ON CAREGIVING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH PEOPLE THAT ARE
HAVE THAT PASSION AND DEDICATION
AT THE LEGISLATIVE LEVEL ON EVEN
WITH AN AGENCY.
AND THE OTHER THING I DID WANT
TO POINT OUT IS THAT WHAT WE DO
WILL BE ANTICIPATING.
IS THAT WE WILL BE PUTTING
TOGETHER --
WE'VE DECIDED AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
EVEN THOUGH WE'RE USUALLY
FINISHED WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
LITTLE MORE TIME.
AND WE ANTICIPATE THAT WE WILL
BE PUTTING TOGETHER A
LEGISLATIVE PACKET.
WITH ABOUT FIVE TO SEVEN
LEGISLATIVE INITIATIVES THAT WE
WILL INTRODUCE TO THE
LEGISLATION THIS FALL AFTER OUR
STRATEGIC PLANNING SESSION.
THAT HAS BEEN GENEROUSLY OFFERED
TO BE HOSTED BY AARP.
OF IN THE NEXT CULT FEW MONTHS
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
I DON'T THINK YOUR FRIENDS OF
THING IS GOING STARTED
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
AND WE DO HAVE UNTIL THE END OF
THE MONTH.
WE DO HAVE ANOTHER THIRTY FIRST
OF JULY.
SOMEONE IN OUR GROUP TODAY IS
THAT YOU DON'T SAY GOODBYE TO
SAY HELLO SO I GUESS THAT'S THE
REAL HURRY NATURE OF THIS.
CHAIR KALRA LET ME BEGIN BY
THANKING YOU FOR YOUR STEADFAST
LEADERSHIP TO THIS COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR INTERESTS AND TODAY'S TOPIC
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'M COME
LUGGAGE THAT WE SAW EXCITED TO
HAVE YOU JOIN US THANK YOU.
AS A STARTED ON AS YOU KNOW I'M
EVERYONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM THAT
CAREGIVER JOURNEY IS VERY UNIQUE
AND VERY PERSONAL.
AND OF THE FIRST SLIDE WE JUST
THAT PERFECT WE JUST HEARD ON
COMMISSIONER BROWN STORY OF
FAMILY CAREGIVING TO LET HER TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE RESOLUTION.
SO IT WAS A TWO YEAR EFFORT AS
PEOPLE HAD ALREADY STATED AND
THE FINAL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON JULY ONE WHICH WE
DID SO THAT PART IS DONE NEXT
LIKE.
THE STRUCTURE OF THE TASK FORCE
ON THE WORK THAT DONNA DESCRIBED
ALL AND COMPLIED WITH THE
RESOLUTION.
THE TWELVE MEMBERS WERE
APPOINTED BY THE ASSEMBLY
SPEAKER IN THE SENATE PRESS TAMS
SIX EACH.
OUTSIDE FUNDING WHICH WAS A
CONDITION OF THE RESOLUTION WAS
SECURED FROM A. R. P. CALIFORNIA
AND ARCHED ON FOUNDATION BOTH OF
WHICH ARE HERE TODAY WITH US AS
WELL.
AND THE LETTER DAVIS SCHOOL OF
GERONTOLOGY RIGHT HERE AT USC
PROVIDED THE ADMINISTRATIVE
SUPPORT [INAUDIBLE]
SLIDE.
THE TASK FORCE HAD A VARIETY OF
OF TASKS TO COMPLETE SO IT
NEEDED TO EXAMINE THE CHALLENGES
FACED BY FAMILY CAREGIVERS AND
EXAMINE THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT
EXISTED. TO IMPROVE CAREGIVER
SUPPORT ACROSS OUR STATE TO
REVIEW THE CURRENT NETWORK.
AND USE THAT KNOWLEDGE TO INFORM
THE LEGISLATURE AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS [INAUDIBLE]
SLIDE.
THE TASK FORCE MEMBERS BROUGHT A
VARIETY OF PERSPECTIVES TO THE
WORK.
THEIR PERSONAL EXPERIENCES THEIR
PROFESSIONAL WORK AND THE
ACADEMIC RESEARCH COMBINED TO
INFLUENCE THE OUTCOME OF THE
REPORT [INAUDIBLE]
FIGHT.
THE LETTER DAVIS SCHOOL OF
GERONTOLOGY SERVED AS THE NON
STATE THAT'S KINDA FUNNY LABEL
BUT THAT WAS THE LABEL IN THE
RESOLUTION NON STATE
ORGANIZATION.
PROVIDING ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT
THE ADMINISTRATIVE AND RESEARCH
TEAM IS LED BY DR KATE WILBUR
WAS SPECIAL ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF
DOCTORAL CANDIDATE KILEY MEYER
WHO'S TAKING CARE OF OUR SLIDES
TODAY.
AND HER ROLE IN ALL THE
LOGISTICS THE VALUE OF THIS
ACADEMIC PARTNER CANNOT BE
UNDERSTATED AND IT WAS IMPACTFUL
TO THE WORK THAT WE DEAD.
THE USC TEAM PROVIDED ALL THE
LOGISTICS NECESSARY TO
COORDINATE THIS TASK FORCE FOR
TWO YEARS.
THEY GAVE US RESEARCHERS WITH
COMPLIMENTARY SKILL SETS AND OF
COURSE THE INSTITUTIONAL
CREDIBILITY AND THE BRANDING OF
THE CALLER.
NEXT SLIDE EPOCHAL.
GOVERNMENT A GOLDEN BLUR ARE
YEAH HOLDEN --
SO WE ACCEPT THAT CAREGIVING CAN
BE HARD WORK.
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT EDUCATION
AND INFORMATION AND TRAINING CAN
MITIGATE THOSE NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES.
RECOMMENDATION NUMBER.
THREE EQUIPPED CAREGIVERS WITH
EASILY ACCESSIBLE INFORMATION
EDUCATION AND TRAINING.
THAT IS SPECIFIC TO THEIR
SITUATION.
AS PROVIDED IN CULTURALLY
COMPETENT AND RELEVANT WAYS
KINDA TOOK YOUR WHOLE SPEECH
ACQUIT RIGHT INTO THAT
RESOLUTION THANK YOU.
THE NEEDS OF CAREGIVERS VERY
BROADLY.
WITH 80% OF CAREGIVERS AND 80%
OF THE CARE GIVERS INDICATING
THEY NEED AND WANT MORE
INFORMATION ON CARE GIVING.
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THE
CAREGIVER SPACE WHEN THEY TRY TO
ACCESS INFORMATION ARE THAT IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY CENTRALIZED.
ITS NOT TAILORED TO MEET THE
UNIQUE NEEDS.
IT'S NOT AVAILABLE AS THE NEEDS
AND THE FAMILY CHANGE DUE TO
MORE COMPLEX CARE THAT'S
REQUIRED.
AND AS WE KNOW THE CARE GIVERS
FROM BY FOR RACIAL ETHNIC
CULTURAL GROUPS DO NOT
NECESSARILY ACCESS INFORMATION
AT THE SAME RIGHT ARE THE SAME
EXTENT AS OTHER CAREGIVERS.
HERE'S OUR ACTIONABLE IS FOR THE
LIST OVER THERE BEAR IF YOU'RE
KEEPING THE ACTIONABLE AROUND
RECOMMENDATION.
THREE THE CHAIRMAN WAYS THAT
ALLOW US TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
PERSONALIZED AND FAMILY CENTERED
MATERIALS.
PROVIDE CULTURALLY COMPETENT
AN INCREASE FUNDING TO THE
CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTERS
TARGETED FOR EDUCATION AND
TRAINING.
RECOMMENDATION NUMBER.
FOUR INCREASE ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE CAREGIVERS SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS INCLUDING RESPITE.
THIS WAS REALLY I AM BROUGHT
HOME TO US REPEATEDLY BY TASK
FORCE MEMBERS AND ALSO AS IN THE
SURVEY THAT WE DID THE OF
ACCESSIBILITY AND AFFORDABILITY
OF SERVICES.
RESPITE SERVICES AS MOST OF YOU
NOW IN THIS IN THIS AUDIENCE
THEY PROVIDE THAT IMPORTANT
BREAK.
FROM CARE GIVING WHETHER IT'S
PLANNED OR BECAUSE OF AN
EMERGENCY SITUATION.
IT'S ONE OF THE MOST SOUGHT OUT
A SERVICES AND IT ONLY 15% OF
CAREGIVERS ARE ABLE TO USE OUR
ACCESS THAT KIND OF SERVICE.
OTHER KIND OF BARRIERS THAT
INTERFERE WITH OUR SERVICE AND
SUPPORT NETWORK FOR CAREGIVERS
HAS TO DO WITH THE AVAILABILITY
CRITICALLY ACUTE IN OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES I COME OUT OF A
RURAL COMMUNITY AND I KNOW THAT
TO BE.
TRUE.
SHORTAGE OF QUALIFIED PROVIDERS
WHICH SPEAKS TO ALL OF THE OTHER
WORKFORCE ISSUES THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CONSTANTLY.
AND THE COST.
ACTIONABLE IS AROUND
RECOMMENDATION FOR DIRECTIONS
FOR LEGISLATION OR OTHER
ADVOCACY WORK.
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF RESPITE
PROVIDERS BY ALLOCATING INCREASE
FUNDING.
AND EXPAND ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
REST RESPITE SERVICES EITHER BY
CONSIDERING TRAINED VOLUNTEER
PROGRAMS AS AN APPROACH.
AND OUR EXTENDED SERVICES ON THE
SLIDING SCALE LIKE WE SOMETIMES
DO WITH OTHER PROGRAMS.
THE NEXT NIGHT.
NEARLY 50% OF FAMILY CAREGIVERS
MIGHT NOT KNOW THIS YOU MIGHT IT
MIGHT BE ONE OF THE IS NEARLY
50% OF FAMILY CAREGIVERS REPORT.
THAT THEY ARE ACTUALLY ASSISTING
WITH PROVIDING MEDICAL CARE. TO
THEIR FAMILY MEMBER WHETHER THAT
IS MEDICATION MANAGEMENT WHETHER
IT'S WORTH CARE WHETHER IT'S
PREPARING SPECIAL DIETS.
ON THIS IS DUE TO INCREASINGLY
COMPLEX AND ACUTE CONDITIONS.
DIAGNOSIS THAT A PERSON MAY HAVE
THAT REQUIRES THEM TO USE A
CAREGIVER.
OR IT MAY BE LINKED TO A
HOSPITAL DISCHARGE.
CAREGIVERS SHOULD BE RECOGNIZED
AS KEY MEMBERS OF THE HEALTHCARE
TEAM.
AND YET WE KNOW THEIR ROLE IS
OFTEN UNDER RECOGNIZED.
RECOMMENDATION NUMBER
[INAUDIBLE]
FIVE BUT BACK.
BUT THE FACT THAT CATCH ME
RECOMMENDATION NUMBER.
FIVE INTEGRATE CAREGIVERS IN THE
HOSPITAL PROCESSES.
SUPPORT THEM AND NAVIGATING AND
TARA AND CARE TRANSITIONS AND
WITH PROVIDING CARE AS IT GETS
MORE COMPLEX IN THEIR SITUATION.
AND RECOGNIZES DONNA SAID
EARLIER THE CAREGIVER'S CHOICE
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT THEY CAN
AND ARE COMFORTABLE WITH DOING
COMPLEX CARE NEEDS.
SO HOW DO WE GET TO THIS
RECOMMENDATION THE ACTIONABLE IS
AROUND RECOMMENDATION NUMBER.
FIVE BRING CALIFORNIA ALIGNED
WITH OTHER STATES.
AND ALLOW NURSES TO DELEGATE
SOME PASSED A QUALIFIED HOME
HEALTH PROVIDERS.
HOSPITAL DISCHARGE PLANNING IS
OFTEN MISSED OPPORTUNITIES. TO
PROVIDE THE SUPPORT FOR FAMILY
CAREGIVERS.
STANDARD PROTOCOLS AND
PROCEDURES AT HOSPITAL DISCHARGE
SHOULD BE RECOGNIZED AND INCLUDE
FAMILY CAREGIVERS ONCE THAT
CAREGIVER IS IDENTIFIED.
ENHANCE CURRENT PROVISIONS OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL IN
FAMILY CAREGIVER LA.
SO THAT YOU ALLOW A PATIENT TO
DECLARE MORE THAN ONE CAREGIVER
SOMEONE SAID TAG YOU'RE IT WILL
SOMETIMES TAKE MULTIPLES ARE IT.
AND IF THE FORMS DON'T ALLOW YOU
TO CREATE MULTIPLE CAREGIVERS
MISCOMMUNICATION CAN OCCUR
WITHIN THE HOME SETTING.
AND ENSURE ACCESS TO TELEHEALTH
FOR BOTH CAREGIVERS AND
RECIPIENTS [INAUDIBLE]
ASIDE.
CALIFORNIA WAS THE FIRST STATE
OF THE NATION TO ADDRESS THE
IMPACT OF COGNITIVE DISORDERS ON
FAMILIES WITH THE CREATION OF
THE CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTER
NETWORK.
THE ELEVEN CAREGIVER RESOURCE
CENTER SERVICE A POINT OF ENTRY.
SERVICES AVAILABLE FOR CARE
GIVING FAMILIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
WELL EACH CENTER TAILORS IT'S
ITS WORK TO THE OBJECT GRAPHIC
AREA AT SERVICE.
WE KNOW THE ALL ELEVEN OF THE
CAREGIVER RESOURCES HAVE A CARE
COMPONENT OF PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE INFORMATION.
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT.
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE. FOR
THE CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTERS
IS CURRENTLY AT THREE PLUS
BILLION [INAUDIBLE]
REPRESENTING.
A 74% DECREASE FROM THE TWO
THOUSAND NINE LEVEL.
RECOMMENDATION NUMBER SIX
INCREASE FUNDING TO CALIFORNIA'S
CAREGIVER RESOURCE CENTERS SO
THAT THEY CAN.
SPAN SERVICES NEXT.
UP THE BACK I'M IS THAT SO THAT
SO THAT THE RESOURCE CENTERS CAN
EXPANSIVENESS TO MEET THE
GROWING DEMAND AS YOU ALL SET BY
AN INCREASE IN AGING POPULATION.
ADMINISTER CAREGIVER ASSESSMENTS
BY BY PROFESSIONALS.
EXPAND RESPITE CARE VIA
RECOMMENDATIONS WE MADE EARLIER.
PROVIDE EVIDENCE BASED EDUCATION
AND TRAINING PROGRAMS AND
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
INNOVATIVE AND COST EFFECTIVE
PROGRAMS.
AS I WIND UP AND WE COMPLETE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT'S A GOOD
LAUNDRY LIST.
MAYBE TOO MUCH OF A LAUNDRY LIST
DONNA PROMISED YOU FIVE OR SEVEN
AS WE CONTINUE TO BRING THAT WE
FIND THOSE AND BRING THOSE BACK.
SO I DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE ON THE NEXT SLIDE THAT
THERE ARE TWO GOVERNMENTAL
FUNDED CAREGIVER SUPPORT
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE TOP ONE IS AN EIGHTEEN POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS EVER TAKE
FEDERAL FUNDS OF THE OLDER
AMERICANS ACT.
AWARDED TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING DISTRIBUTION
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL FOR
CAREGIVERS SUPPORT REFERRAL
ETCETERA.
AND THE STATE GENERAL FUND AS WE
JUST MENTIONED FLOW THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO THE CAREGIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS.
AT THE WORK OF THE TASK FORCE
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ACCOMPLISHED
WITHOUT THE GENEROSITY THE
VISION AND THE COMMITMENT OF OUR
CHIU FUNDERS.
AARP CALIFORNIA AND I STONE
FOUNDATION WE ARE SO
APPRECIATIVE OF YOUR WORK.
MURRAY OF THE PROCESS OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IS JUST THE TIP
OF THE ICEBERG THAT WHOLE BIG
DOCUMENT HAS MANY MORE
RECOMMENDATIONS THE RATIONALE
THAT YOU WOULD NEED.
SO TODAY MISTER CHAIR MEMBER.
WE UNDERSTAND WILLING TO WORK
WITH YOU TO ADVANCE THESE --
RECOMMENDATIONS AND PROPOSALS ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA'S MANY
FAMILY CAREGIVERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SANDY DR BENTON FOR
GOING OVER THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS --
OFFICIALLY BUT I THINK OF GREAT
THOROUGHNESS AS WELL AS THANK
YOU BOTH SO MUCH.
R. MOVEON DE ET OUT COMING FROM.
MY NECK OF THE WOODS OF NORTH A
DISCUSS ISSUES OF DIVERSITIES A
DIVERSITY ISSUES IN CAREGIVING.
THANK YOU CHAIR --
KALRA AND ALSO ASSEMBLY.
COM LAGER DOVE --
SO FIRST OF ALL I JUST WANNA SAY
THAT.
EVERYONE WHO TAKES ON THE
CAREGIVING ROLE DOES IT OUT OF
LOVE MOST PEOPLE DO IT OUT OF
LOVE ADAM AND THEY WANT THE BEST
CARE FOR THEIR FAMILY MEMBER --
AND THIS CUTS ACROSS ALL RACES
ALL ETHNICITIES PRETTY MUCH ALL
SEGMENTS OF THE POPULATION.
BUT THERE ARE DIFFERENCES IN
FACT THERE ARE STUDIES THAT ARE
SHOWING THAT LATINOS SPEND MORE
TIME.
IN CAREGIVING THAN ALL THE OTHER
GROUPS --
LGBT INDIVIDUALS ARE MORE LIKELY
TO BECOME CAREGIVERS MAN.
SOMETIMES BY DEFAULT BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE CHILDREN AND
THEREFORE IT'S ASSUME THAT
YOU'LL BE THE CAREGIVER FOR MOM
AND DAD --
AND THEY ARE ALSO MORE LIKELY TO
DELAY SEEKING OUT SERVICES DUE
TO DISCRIMINATION OR FEAR OF
DISCRIMINATION.
WE'VE ALSO FOUND THAT AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND LATINOS SPEND A
HIGHER PROPORTION OF THEIR
INCOME ON OUT OF POCKET CARE.
THAN WHITES IN CAUCASIAN AND OF
WHITES AND ASIANS SO 44% VERSUS
34% [INAUDIBLE]
I'M.
I THINK THE YOU KNOW AND EVEN
THOSE WHO ARE FINANCIALLY ABLE
TO CARE FOR THEIR LOVED.
ONE IT IS EXTREMELY COST
PROHIBITIVE AND SO THAT'S ONE OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS WE SAW WHICH
IS TO LOOK AT ON THE FINANCIAL
COST OF CARE GIVING. ONE OF THE
OTHER THINGS THAT --
YOU'RE ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WAS TO EQUIP
CAREGIVERS WITH EARLY ACCESSIBLE
INFORMATION AND TRAINING --
AND YOU KNOW CARE GIVERS ARE AT
RISK OF BURNOUT AND DEPRESSION
AS WAS ALLUDED EARLIER.
AND IT'S EVEN HARDER FOR
CAREGIVERS WHO ARE OF A
PARTICULAR UNDER REPRESENTED
GROUPS TO LOOK FOR SERVICES TO
SEEK OUT INFORMATION AND SO
MAKES IT THAT MUCH HARDER FOR
THEM TO ACTUALLY ACCESS SERVICES
THAT MAY BE READILY AVAILABLE.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW WHERE TO
LOOK OR IT THAT INFORMATION IS
NOT AVAILABLE THE FOR EXAMPLE
THE PAID FAMILY LEAVE ACT IF
THERE'S INFORMATION ABOUT IT AT
THEIR WORKPLACE.
BUT IT'S NOT IN SPANISH THEY
HAVE NO IDEA THAT THEY CAN
ACTUALLY ACCESS THIS PARTICULAR.
ITEM PROGRAM.
LIKEWISE IF SOMEONE HAS A
PARTICULAR --
CONDITION AND THEY DON'T KNOW
HOW TO PROVIDE CARE FOR THAT
CONDITION OF IT'S NOT AVAILABLE
IN LANGUAGE OR IN SOME WAY THAT
THEY CAN UNDERSTAND IT IT MAKES
IT THAT MUCH HARDER.
I AM SO IT'S REALLY CRITICAL
THAT ANY SERVICES WE PROVIDE DO
IT DOES HAVE THAT CULTURAL
RELEVANCE TO IT AND THERE ARE
SOME PROGRAMS IN THE STATE THAT
DO A GREAT JOB OF PROVIDING.
SERVICES THAT ARE TAILORED IN
SUCH A WAY BUT WE NEED MORE OF
THAT AND WE NEED MORE MATERIALS
IN IN VARIOUS LANGUAGES --
I OTHERS CAN HAVE GIVES SOME
REAL LIFE EXAMPLES --
YOU KNOW LAST YEAR I TALKED WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE AIDE WHO WAS --
ACTUALLY TALKING TO US ABOUT HER
OWN FATHER WHO HAD A DEMENTIA
AND SHE WAS WONDERING WHAT
SERVICES ARE OUT THERE AND SHE
HAD EXPLORED ALL THE SERVICES.
BUT ULTIMATELY SHE DECIDED THAT
YOU KNOW THE BEST THING IS
PROBABLY FOR ME TO SEND MY
FATHER BACK TO KOREA.
NOT BECAUSE THERE ARE BETTER
SERVICES THERE BUT BECAUSE SHE
KNEW THAT HE WOULD AT LEAST BE
AROUND PEOPLE WHO UNDERSTOOD THE
CULTURE AND THE LANGUAGE.
AND THAT IS NOT UNCOMMON TO MANY
MANY CAREGIVERS IN CALIFORNIA
MAY END UP SENDING THEIR LOVED
ONE BACK TO THEIR COUNTRY OF
ORIGIN FOR THIS VERY REASON --
AND SIMILARLY --
YOU KNOW CHARLES CHO WHO WAS
THAT.
NOBEL PRIZE WINNER --
THEY LIVED IN MOUNTAIN VIEW UP
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND WE
ARE YOU KNOW THE WIFE DID AS
BEST AS SHE COULD TO PROVIDE THE
CARE BUT AND LOOKED AT ALL THE
SERVICES AROUND.
IT WAS REALLY HARD THEY COULD
AFFORD THE CARE BUT IT WAS VERY
HARD FOR THEM TO LOOK FOR
SERVICES AND ULTIMATELY THEY TO
DECIDE TO MOVE BACK TO HONG KONG.
AGAIN NOT BECAUSE THERE ARE
THERE BETTER SERVICES THERE FOR
ALZHEIMERS OR DEMENTIA BUT AGAIN
BECAUSE OF THAT CULTURAL NATURE
OF IT.
SO I THINK WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT
CALIFORNIA AND YOU KNOW ALL THE
INNOVATION AND THE
PROGRESSIVENESS WE HAVE HERE.
A CAN CERTAINLY BE A SINKHOLE
FOR CAREGIVERS EMOTIONALLY
FINANCIALLY AND SOCIALLY.
ARM YOU KNOW WHEN WHEN WE WERE
TRYING TO FIGURE THIS OUT HOME
[INAUDIBLE]
SO.
THE HIGHLIGHT HERE IS REALLY
AROUND THE CULTURALLY TAILORED
EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS BUT YOU
NOTICE AGAIN THINKING ABOUT
WHATEVER IT IS THAT WE DO OUR
THAT WE REALLY LOOK AT THE
DIVERSITY OF OUR OF OUR STATE OF
THE CAREGIVERS AROUND AND
INCLUDING OUR LGBT CHARACTERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THEM
GREAT POINTS PLEA AGREE.
OTHER EN DIE I THINK IT SAID
APPROPRIATE AROUND THIS OUT.
IF THE DOCTOR KATHLEEN WILBUR I
HEAR USC AJAY DISCUSS EMERGING
FAMILY CAREGIVER CHALLENGES.
SO I THANK YOU CHAIRMAN KALRA
AND NUMBER CAN LINGER DOT OF AND
I WANT TO START BY SAYING HOW
GRATEFUL I AM TO LIVE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WHERE WE HAVE AMAZING LEADERSHIP
WHO CARES ABOUT?
OF PROVIDING BASIC SERVICES AND
THE HUMAN DIGNITY OF ALL OUR
RESIDENTS SO --
WE START FROM A GOOD PLACE AND
WE START FROM A PLACE OF
LEADERSHIP.
ARM I ALSO WANT TO THANK
COMMISSIONER BROWN FOR HER
VISION AND LEADERSHIP IN MAKING --
THIS.
PROGRAM A REALITY AND OF COURSE
AS THE OTHER PANEL MEMBERS THE A
A RP AND ARCHED ON FOUNDATIONS
FOR THEIR CHEN SUPPORT.
THAT MADE THIS ALL HAPPENED I
WANT TO THANK AND ACKNOWLEDGE
THE HARD WORKING TASK FORCE
MEMBERS.
A AND THE LEADERSHIP OF DONNA
BENTON.
AND SANDY FITS PATRICK.
SANDY FITS PATRICK AND THE
SUPPORT OF KILEY WHO HAS BEEN
MENTIONED BEFORE [INAUDIBLE]
SO.
A LITTLE BIT PREACHING TO THE
CHOIR HERE BUT CAREGIVING IS A
UNIVERSAL ISSUE AND AS FORMER
FIRST LADY ROSALYNN CARTER SAID.
THERE'S FOUR KINDS OF PEOPLE.
THOSE WHO WILL BE CARE GIVERS.
THOSE WHO ARE CAREGIVERS THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN CARE GIVERS AND
THOSE WHO WILL BE CARE RECEIVERS.
AND FOR MANY OF US IF WE LIVE
LONG ENOUGH WILL BE SEVERAL OF
THOSE ARE.
SEVERAL OF THOSE [INAUDIBLE]
SO [INAUDIBLE]
I'M.
TRYING TO GET MY HEAD AROUND.
WHAT'S FIFTY EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS LOOK LIKE THAT'S WHAT
CAREGIVERS CONTRIBUTE SO OF IF
YOU WOULD PUT THE SLIDE UP
THINKING ABOUT THAT.
I CALIFORNIA STATE MEDI CAL
LOOKS TO BE ABOUT THIRTY BILLION
AYE ANNUAL APPLE --
PROFITS.
MY MERE FORTY ONE BILLION.
THE GDP OF CROATIA WHO WAS THE
RUNNER UP IN THE WORLD CUP.
FIFTY SIX BILLION.
SO HERE WE ARE OF THE CARE GIVER
OF CONTRIBUTION IS MORE.
THAN ALL OF THOSE [INAUDIBLE]
I'M.
AND YOU'VE HEARD THIS AND YOU
ALL KNOW IT BUT I THE STORY OF
FAMILY CAREGIVING IS REPEATED
EVERY DAY.
ACROSS OUR STATE IN URBAN AND
RURAL COMMUNITIES RICH AND POOR
DIFFERENT KINDS OF FAMILIES
DIFFERENT KINDS OF CARE GIVERS
[INAUDIBLE]
I'M.
DONNA TALKED ABOUT PRESENT
TURGEON ISM THAT.
SOUND LIKE A RELIGION HAS.
DONE SO --
THE NEXT SLIDE US SO I HAD TO GO
TO THE DENTIST RECENTLY TO GET A
CROWN AND I PUT IT OFF AND
FINALLY HAD TO DO IT.
AND YOU KNOW HOW YOU KIND OF
PRIME THE DENTIST.
AND HAVE YOU BEEN CAMPING LATELY
BECAUSE I KNOW HE LIKES TO DO
THAT.
AND HE SAID NO HE HAD SPEND
SPENDING NIGHT AND WEEKENDS
CAREGIVING FOR HIS DYING FATHER
WHO'S.
SO I HAD CONCERNS ABOUT HIM AND
I CONCERNS ABOUT ME THEM
THINKING I AT KNOWING HOW
EXHAUSTING AND THIS KIND OF WORK
YEAH -- BUT
I HAVE.
I HAVE MY CROWN.
YEAH BUT IT WAS FLYING AND AND I
WANT TO FOLLOW UP WITH WITH HIM
WITH OF THE WORK THAT HE'S DOING
AND I LEARNED A LOT ABOUT HIS
FATHER TO WHICH WAS VERY
TOUCHING.
MANY OF YOU I THINK ALMOST
EVERYBODY HERE PROBABLY KNOWS
FERNANDO TORRES GAL WHO'S BEEN A
GREAT LEADER IN OUR STATE IN AND
THE COUNTRY AN AGING FOR THE
LAST FOUR DECADES.
AND FAMILY A FERNANDO AND HIS
EIGHT SIBLINGS [INAUDIBLE]
WERE RAISED.
BY A SINGLE MAMAN AND AS MANY OF
YOU KNOW FERNANDO WHEN HE WAS
SIX MONTHS OLD CONTRACTED POLIO
HE SPENT A LOT OF HIS EARLY
YEARS IN AND OUT OF THE HOSPITAL.
ON ALL THE KIDS WENT TO COLLEGE
THEY WERE ALL VERY SUCCESSFUL IN
FERNANDO SAID SOMETHING I
THOUGHT WAS REALLY COMPELLING
WHICH IS. ONE MOM RAISE THOSE
NINE KIDS BUT WHEN THE MOMMY TO
CAREGIVING IN A AND THEY CAME
FROM ALL OVER THE STATE AND THEY
REARRANGED WORK AND THEY THEY
SCHEDULED.
AND HE SAID THAT NINE KIDS HAD A
REALLY HARD TIME.
TRYING TO MANAGE THE CAREGIVING
FOR THE ONE MOM.
AND I THINK THAT THAT REALLY
SHOWS THE STRUGGLES THAT
FAMILIES --
MAKE.
THIS IS THE COMMUNITY CENTER
BECAUSE FERNANDO'S MOM ALSO
AFTER SHE RAISE THE NINE KIDS
GAVE BACK A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
THE COMMUNITY.
AND THEY RECOGNIZED HER BY
NAMING A COMMUNITY CENTER AFTER.
I'M NO ONE OR MANY OF US DON'T
EXPECT TO BE A CAREGIVER AND
WHILE OF THE TASK FORCE WAS
DOING ITS WORK I UNEXPECTEDLY.
BECAME A CAREGIVER FOR MY
HUSBAND.
WHO -- WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH A TERMINAL
ILLNESS.
AND I HAD EVERY POSSIBLE GOOD
CAREGIVING SUPPORT THAT YOU
COULD HAVE FLEXIBLE WORK.
ON FAMILY MEMBERS WILLING TO
FILL IN REALLY GREAT OF PEOPLE
THAT I WORK WITH ADEQUATE
FINANCIAL.
RESOURCES AND THIS CAREGIVING
TIME WAS A GIFT.
AND IT WAS REALLY REALLY HARD.
AND IT SORT OF THINKING ABOUT IT.
ARM ANY UNEXPECTED THINGS SO.
ONE OF THE THINGS IS YOU DON'T
MY HUSBAND ALWAYS SAID
EVERYTHING THAT HE DID AND I
ALWAYS LIKE.
BUT IT TURNS OUT ALL THE THINGS
HE DID FROM THE ERRANDS TO THE
SHOPPING TO CHANGING THE KITTY
LITTER TO OPENING JARS THAT WAS
ALWAYS A PROBLEM.
AND THEN THAT ALL GOES AWAY ON
AND THEN --
TO TAKE ON ALL THAT YOU TAKE ON
THE ROLE.
AND MY HUSBAND WAS VERY.
FAVORITE SPORTS WERE FOOTBALL.
AND PAIRS SKATING.
SORT OF A STRANGE COMBINATION
NOT.
BUT BUT ONE OF FOR ME I DID
MEDICAL STOP FAN AND OF
TELEHEALTH.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WAS
THE HARDEST WAS TRANSFERRING IN
A COUPLE OF NEAR MISSES.
AND SO WE DECIDED TO MAKE
TRANSFERRING AN OLYMPIC LIKE
PAIRS SKATING ACTIVITY IN WHICH
WE WOULD PLAN AND THEN WE WOULD
RATE OURSELVES SO.
I'M NOT.
I HAVE TO SAY THIS DID NOT
HAPPEN WE HAD A COUPLE OF THE
NURSES.
BUT I THINK THERE'S SO MANY
THINGS AN ECHO EFFECT CAREGIVING
ROLE.
AND AND AS YOU SAID YOU'VE SEEN
ONE CAREGIVER YOU SEEN ONE
CAREGIVER AND PEOPLE WILL HAVE.
I HOPE THAT YOU'LL HEAR FROM US
SOON DIFFERENT STORIES BUT I
THOUGHT A LOT ABOUT [INAUDIBLE]
WHAT IF?
ON I WERE AN HOURLY WORKER AND I
HAD TO PUT IN THOSE HOURS TO GET
PAID.
I OR IF I HAD NO BENEFITS OR IF
I HAD TO BALANCE IN MY GOING TO
PAY THE RENT OR DO SOME OF THE
OUT OF POCKET COSTS THAT NEED TO
HAPPEN.
OR TRADING OFF SOME OF THE CARE
FOR HELPING MY KIDS WITH COLLEGE
NONE OF THAT HAPPENED TO ME.
IN MY CHOICES BUT YOU THINK
ABOUT THE HARD CHOICES AND THE
SACRIFICES AND WHAT PEOPLE.
HAVE TO DO.
AND I ALSO THINK ABOUT AND
SEVERAL PEOPLE SAID TO ME WELL
YOU COULD DO NURSING HOME
PLACEMENT.
I AM AND AGAIN AND KNOWING WHAT
I KNOW IF IT WAS SHOCKING TO ME
THAT THEY SAID IT BUT I
UNDERSTAND AND I UNDERSTAND WHY
FAMILIES HAVE TO DO IT.
PARTICULARLY IF YOU DON'T GET
CAL WHEN YOU'RE GIVING CARE IN
THE HOME BUT YOU DO GET IT IN
THE FACILITY.
AND FACILITIES WHO ARE ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS A DAY SO
IF YOU LOOK AT THE MATTER CAL
BECAUSE FOR PLACEMENT.
HUGE AND ONE OF THE MAJOR --
HOLDING THE FORT AGAINST THOSE
PLACEMENTS ARE THE FAMILY
CAREGIVERS --
I'VE SEEN FAMILIES GET REPORTED
TO A PS.
BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T QUITE
PATCHED TOGETHER ALL THE HOURS
AND MOM DIDN'T WANT TO GO TO THE
NURSING HOME.
I'VE SEEN A WORKER RUSH HOME
FROM HER HAIR SALON BECAUSE SHE
COULDN'T FIND MOM.
ON THE A OF THE MONITOR THAT HER
HER APT MONITOR AND SO SHE WAS
WORRIED.
ON MY SEEN AS YOU'VE HEARD
CAREGIVER SACRIFICE THEIR OWN
HEALTH.
I TRY TO CONTINUE THE CAREGIVING.
I'M SO WE ALL KNOW THAT THIS IS
A REALLY IMPORTANT COMPELLING
ISSUE.
AND THEY'RE HELPING SUPPORT
FAMILY CAREGIVERS HELP SUPPORT.
ALL OF US AND SUPPORT THAT STATE
BUDGET.
I'M SO THINKING ABOUT A NEXT
DOUBTS.
WE ARE ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD
WITH THAT AARP --
RECOMMENDATIONS ARM BUT I ALSO
WANTED -- TO
SUGGEST [INAUDIBLE]
THAT ALONE.
CONTINUING THE WORK OF THE TASK
FORCE AND PEOPLE IS SAID MAYBE
AND AGENCY OR SOMETHING THAT CAN.
PROVIDE SOME ONGOING INPUT SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY.
ON CAREGIVERS ARE EVERYWHERE BUT
THEIR VOICES ARE OFTEN NOT HEARD
ONE OF THE REASONS IS THEY'RE SO
BUSY AND THEY'RE SO EXHAUSTED
AND THEY ALSO THINK FAMILIES
THINK THIS IS OUR JOB.
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
DO.
AND I THINK THEY DON'T RECOGNIZE
THAT THEY DON'T ALWAYS HAVE TO
DO IT.
ALONE SO FAMILIES WILL DO BETTER
CARE GIVING AND FOR LONGER AND
WITH FEWER NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES
IF WE CAN PROVIDE THE SUPPORT.
THAT WAS IN THE POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND I THINK TO CONTINUE TO HEAR
THE VOICE OF THE CAREGIVERS WILL
REALLY BE REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
PEOPLE IN DISABILITY COMMUNITY
SAY NOTHING ABOUT US WITHOUT US.
AND I THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
THING HERE --
I WAS FORTUNATE RECENTLY TO GO
TO EUROPE TO LOOK AT AGE
FRIENDLY CITIES AND WHAT WE
COULD LEARN FROM THEM AND ONE OF
THE BIG TAKEAWAYS WAS THIS
NOTION OF CO PRODUCTION.
WHICH IS TO ENGAGE PEOPLE WHO
WERE LIVING THE EXPERIENCE IN
DEVELOPING.
THE POLICIES IN THE PROGRAMS AND
ADVANCING THINGS FORWARD.
AND BECOMING CHAMPIONS OF
BECOMING THE CHANGE THAT THEY
WANTED TO SEE AND I LOVE THAT
NOTION I THINK THAT
RECOMMENDATIONS.
ALSO LEAD TO THAT SO I THINK WE
HAVE THIS ISSUE IT'S COMPELLING
BUT ONE OF THE REASONS WE HAVE
IT IS THE GREATEST I THINK
ACHIEVEMENT --
IN THE TWENTIETH TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY WHICH IS LONGEVITY.
SO WE HAVE AN AGING POPULATION
AND THAT'S A GOOD THING AND I
THINK WE CAN MAKE IT EVEN BETTER
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR DOCTOR
WILBUR AND BEFORE WE THANK OUR
WONDERFUL PANEL HERE I JUST
WANNA.
A BETTER BUT YOU KNOW --
THAT WILL BE TAKING A FIVE
MINUTE BREAK TO A TO A FIVE IS
NOT HELPING TO SUPPORT TO LONG
RIGHT.
WE GET UP STRUGGLING UNDER THE
IS RESTING HIS RESTROOM AND
SPEAKING OF WHICH THERE ARE
RESTROOMS OUTSIDE THEIR SIMPLY
RUSSIANS OUTSIDE THE COURT YOUR
TO THE RIGHT.
OR YOU CAN GO ACROSS THE STREET
TO RONALD TUTOR HALL THEIR
RESTROOMS ON THE FIRST WHERE
THERE.
AND SO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY GETS
UP IN THE NEXT FEW MINUTES LEASE
MOVES AROUND TALK TO PEOPLE.
ARE AND LET'S THANK THIS
EXTRAORDINARY PANEL OF FOR
HELPING INSTEAD FOCUS ON THANK
YOU.
AND THERE'S A COUPLE OF THINGS I
THINK THAT I JUST ONE OF THE
FIRST OF ALL THE PANEL
[INAUDIBLE]
IS FANTASTIC WHAT THEY SAID I
CONCURRENT WITH 1100%.
AND I DIDN'T CONCUR WITH THEM
BEFOREHAND ON ON WHAT THEY WERE
GOING TO SAY.
BUT WHAT THEY'RE SAYING IS.
JEFF WHY WE HAD TO HAVE THIS
TASK FORCE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
BUT I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
INTRODUCE ANY OF THE TASK
MEMBERS.
TASK FORCE MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE
WHO'VE WORKED FOR TWO YEARS. TO
DO THIS AND IF ANY OF THEM THAT
ARE HERE.
AND THE DONNA DOESN'T MY YEAH I
WAS GONNA DO THAT VERY AND THIS
IS A GREAT TIME TO DO IT I THINK
BUT MY LOGIC OF THE FACT.
THAT IF WE CAN HAVE ALL THE TASK
FORCE MEMBERS PLEASE STAND UP
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
ALL THE BECAUSE OF A FEW AND
LET'S THANK THEM FOR THE FINAL
WORK IT IS.
SOME OF WHOM HAD THEM LEAVE SO
THAT THEY COULD DO CARE GIVING
SOME PLAZA THE HELL THAT.
AND I ALSO WANTED TO INTRODUCE A
BETSY BUTLER WHO IS THE VICE
CHAIR OF THE COMMISSION ON AGING
IN PHILLY RIGHT OVER THERE OF
THE SHE I CAN GO HOME.
A POINT OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE
WOULD BE.
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE THE LADIES
THAT SAME WITH ME AND THAT SARAH
GARCIA AND COMES FROM IMPERIAL
COUNTY.
DON'T FORGET HER COUNTY.
EVITA DEAN WHO COMES FROM YUCCA
VALLEY.
AND SHE SAID PLEASE DON'T FORGET
HER BECAUSE SHE'S OUT THERE.
AND MARGARET MICKENS WHO IS IN
SAMBOR MEDINA THEY'VE ALWAYS
THEIR HANDS BACK WHERE THEY CAME
WITH ME.
LASTLY I'D LIKE --
TO JUST THE KIND OF TALK ABOUT A
MINUTE WHAT.
MORE RICO YAMADA DID.
BEFORE BEFORE I CAME ON AS THE
CHAIR SHE WAS THE CHAIR OF AGING
AND LONG TERM CARE.
AND WHAT SHE DID ONE YEAR WAS TO
SAY.
THE YOU KNOW WE ONLY GOT A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN THIS WHOLE BUDGET OF ALL
THESE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
BENEFIT WHAT ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT.
SHE SAID WE GOT A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AND SHE
WAS SO DISMAYED ABOUT IT.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS SHE WAS
ABLE TO DO.
AND WE DID TOGETHER WAS A THING
CALLED FACES OF A KING.
AND IF YOU GO BACK AND LOOK AT
THAT REPORT.
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT THEY'VE
BEEN SAYING ABOUT LGBT ABOUT --
AFRICAN AMERICANS ABOUT.
EVERYONE ASIANS YOU'LL FIND IT
IN THAT PARTICULAR REPORT
BECAUSE WE DID A SERIES.
PUBLIC HEARINGS ON THAT.
AND I WANT TO SAY THANKS AGAIN
TO YOU.
I WANT TO SAY THANKS THAT I
THINK IF VENN GOOD HANDS I THINK
THEY YOU.
AND SYDNEY --
IMPLIED ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ONLY PEPPER INTO.
WILL WILL REALLY TAKE IT WHERE
IT NEEDS TO GO AND ANYTHING YOU
NEED ME TO DO.
I'LL BE THERE.
THANK YOU SO I WAS COMMISSIONER
WE REALLY REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND I'M GONNA START OFF AT TWO
TEN AND WWE HERE RESPONDENTS SO
PLEASE.
ALBUM GET UP STRETCH AROUND TO
READ BACK YEARS BECAUSE OUR
PROMPTLY AT TWO TEN THANK YOU
ALL [INAUDIBLE]
A PER.
WE'LL LEAVE YOU WE ALREADY LOST
WHAT'S MEMBERS.
ABOUT THE THREE OF US
[INAUDIBLE]
NO.
I LOOK AT THE HOW MIGRATION THAT
[INAUDIBLE]
WELCOME [INAUDIBLE]
TEST.
RAISE THEIR HAND
[INAUDIBLE]
RIGHT.
SO AFTER THAT GREAT START.
LEARNING MORE ABOUT THE ACTUAL
REPORT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US. TO GET RESPONSES TO IT
FROM A FROM A WIDE RANGE OF
STAKEHOLDERS THAT'S WHAT.
OTHER NEXT. THIRTY MINUTES GOING
TO BE A BALBOA GONNA ALLOW EACH
OTHER OF OUR FOLKS APPEAR ON THE
PANEL FIVE MINUTES. FOR THEIR
REFLECTION.
THAT NOTHING I HAVE OUR OWN BOB
ABOUT FIVE MINUTES.
WELL THE PROBLEM I BUT NO
PROMISES REFLECT ON THE NUMBER
OF FLATS.
AND NOT BASED UPON.
BASED UPON AND I AM YOU KNOW
COMING FROM A GROUP THE
REPRESENTING.
AMBER AND I WILL HAVE SOME TIME
FOR SOME PUBLIC COMMENT AS WELL
[INAUDIBLE]
SO.
BOB WANTED TO COSTA OKAY SURE
[INAUDIBLE]
I ARE MY NAME IS BOB WELCH AND
UP I'M ACTUALLY I'M THE CONSUMER
AYE EE.
THE CARE GIVER --
PORTION OF THE TASK FORCE.
AND OUT I JUST WANT TO SAY HOW
HONORED I AM TO HAVE BEEN
SELECTED TO BE PART OF THE
COMMITTEE AND HOW WONDERFUL IT'S
BEEN TO INTERFACE WITH.
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF OUR TASK
FORCE AS WELL AS THE PEOPLE FROM
THE ACADEMIC WORLD RICHEST A
WONDERFUL EXPERIENCE.
BOB.
AND I LOOK AT REBEKAH MY LIFE
AND ALL THE UPS AND DOWNS.
I'M SURE WE'VE ALL EXPERIENCED --
I CERTAINLY WOULD HAVE PICTURED
MYSELF SITTING HERE TODAY
SPEAKING TO YOU.
ARE ABOUT CAREGIVING --
BUT JOHN.
ROSS JUST STARTED HOW DID I GET
HERE.
WHAT WORK ON HERE FORTY FIVE
YEARS AGO MY --
FIANCE WHO'S NOW MY WIFE.
AND I WERE SITTING ACROSS THE
DESK FROM.
THE CHIEF OF NEUROLOGY AT ALBANY
MEDICAL ALBANY MEDICAL CENTER.
ARE ALICE HAD YA JUST HAD.
WHAT WAS WAS ACTUALLY OUR FIRST
EXACERBATIONS?
ARE AND SHE WAS DIAGNOSED WITH A
BATTERY OF TESTS.
AND JOBS.
ARE HE WAS.
PRESENTING THE RESULTS TO US IN.
HE STARTED OUT BY SAYING WELL
GOOD NEWS IS YOU KNOW HAD A
BRAIN TUMOR [INAUDIBLE]
HOWEVER.
I REALLY FEEL THAT YOU HAVE
MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS AND THAT WAS
BEFORE THE DAYS OF THEM ARE AYE
SO YOU REALLY COULDN'T.
WE KNOW FOR SURE THAT SHE HAD
ALL THE THE REAL --
TELLTALE SYMPTOMS WHICH DEFTLY
TURNED OUT TO BE TRUE.
SO.
OF INNOCENCE THAT WAS THE
BEGINNING OF OUR OUR JOURNEY HE
SAID.
IT ALL I CAN TELL YOU RIGHT NOW
IS GO OUT AND LIVE YOUR LIFE --
BECAUSE AS I'M SURE MOST OF YOU
NOW THEIR THERE'S NO NO BECAUSE
WERE KNOWN CURE AT THAT TIME NOR
IS THERE FORTY FIVE YEARS LATER.
SO HERE WE ARE LIVING OUR LIVES
WE DID JUST WHAT HE SAID.
SO BEING A YOUNG AND INVINCIBLE --
WE WENT AHEAD AND GOT MARRIED A
YEAR LATER --
EYE SURGEON NEW JOB THAT WE
MOVED ALL TO SYRACUSE NEW YORK A
WE HAD TWO CHILDREN.
AND LIVED OF SAY.
YEAH NORMAL LIFE FOR THE NEXT
FIFTEEN YEARS OUSTED HAS SOME OF
EXACERBATIONS ALL [INAUDIBLE]
WHICH YEAH PUT HER DOWN FOR A
LITTLE BIT TO KNOW THAT SHE
WOULD COVERED REALLY RECOVER
LIKE A LOT OF PEOPLE DO WITH
RELAPSING REMITTING.
MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS.
ARM.
BUT THERE ARE.
ABOUT FIFTEEN YEARS INTO IT OF
SHE HAD EXACERBATIONS THAT.
SHE JUST COULDN'T GET UP AND
WALK AGAIN SO THAT REALLY BEGAN
ARE.
WE WHAT I CONSIDER MY JOURNEY
FROM JUST BEING A HUSBAND A
FATHER TO LIKE LIKE PHASE ONE OF
BEING A CAREGIVER [INAUDIBLE]
ARE.
AND AT THAT POINT OF TIME IS
WHEN WE ARE WIDENING DOORWAYS --
YEAH.
ADJUSTED TOILETS ARE GOT RAMPS
IN THE HOUSE A STEER.
STEER LEFT GOING THE SECOND
FLOOR AND DOG ELECTRIC
WHEELCHAIRS AT CENTER
[INAUDIBLE]
SO -- THAT
WAS THE BEGINNING OF IT ALL
[INAUDIBLE]
ARE. ONE THING I JUST WANT TO
SAY THOUGH THAT EVEN THOUGH
[INAUDIBLE]
OF SHE DIDN'T.
I DECLINED A PHYSICALLY REAL
FAST THERE WERE THERE WERE STILL
YOU KNOW THE GRADUAL DECLINE AS
WELL AS A LOT OF EMOTIONAL
ROLLERCOASTER.
THAT YOU YOU ALSO GET WITH
MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS SO WE HAD WE
HAD TO DEAL WITH THAT WHICH IF
WE HAVE LONG TERM EFFECTS WHICH
I'LL GET INTO A LITTLE BIT LATER
[INAUDIBLE]
SO -- YOU'RE
KIDDING HAS MANY PEOPLE SAY CARE
GIVING IN REGARDLESS OF THE
SITUATION USUALLY.
ARE.
IT ACTUALLY COMES IN PHASES AND
ARE THE NATURE OF THE ILLNESS OR
DISEASE REALLY DICTATES --
WHERE YOU AT WITH YOUR YOUR
POINT OF CARE AT THAT POINT OF
TIME [INAUDIBLE]
OF SO.
WHAT WOULD DONE IT WE DECIDED TO
DO [INAUDIBLE]
WAS IRAN [INAUDIBLE]
JUST.
COULD A LIKE IF THEY CONTINUE ON
WITH OUR LIFE I WAS I WAS A
SALESPERSON FOR MEDICAL COMPANY
THAT -- IT'S
GREAT THAT I WAS INVOLVED
MEDICALLY BECAUSE THAT GAVE ME A
LOT OF CONFIDENCE TO DO.
WHATEVER I NEED TO DO AS A
CAREGIVER BOTH THEN AND YOU KNOW --
DOWN THE ROAD [INAUDIBLE]
A SO.
I WAS ABLE TO DO MY JOB.
ARE WHICH IS VERY FORTUNATE FROM
WHAT I SEE.
A UNITED PEOPLE OUT THERE THAT
HAS -- THE
NO THEY HAVE TO BE A AND A NINE
TO FIVE JOB BEING A SALES PERSON
GIVES YOU A LITTLE BIT MORE.
LEEWAY AS TO WHICH YOU WANT TO
DO AND I ENDED UP WORKING FOR A
LOT OF GREAT PEOPLE WHO
UNDERSTOOD MY SITUATION AND
WHERE WE'RE WILLING TO WORK WITH
ME.
A I BECAME A REGIONAL MANAGER
COVERED THE WHOLE NORTHEAST AND
I WAS ABLE TO DO THAT. FOR FOR
QUITE AWHILE [INAUDIBLE]
BUT OF IN.
TWO THOUSAND ONE YOU KNOW
EVERYTHING CHANGED --
WE LOST OUR YOUNGEST CHILD OR OR
OR SIGNED.
OF BOBBY WHO WAS SEVENTEEN AT
THE TIME IN A CAR ACCIDENT BASED
ON YOUR BAD WEATHER.
SO THAT JUST THREW EVERYTHING
OUT OF WHACK AND ON WE ARE.
WHAT HAPPENED FROM THAT POINT IS
ON MY DAUGHTER?
DROPPED OUT OF COLLEGE --
AND WHEN SHE DID RETURN SHIA TO
SCHOOL SHE ENDED UP COMING OUT
TO THE WEST COAST.
AND I WENT TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO AND GATS HOW WE
ENDED UP COMING OUT HERE AS WELL
[INAUDIBLE]
ON IN TWO THOUSAND ONE I WAS NO
LONGER ABLE TO KEEP UP THE
TRAVEL INVOLVED WITH BEING A
MANAGER.
SO PA I TOOK ANOTHER JOB AT AGE
FIFTY FIVE I WAS FORTUNATELY
ABLE TO A YOU CHANGE OR NOT MY
CAREER I STILL STATE MEDICAL.
BY DOG.
I DID THAT FOR YEAR AND THEN WE
I WAS ABLE TO GET A TERRITORY
OUT HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO WE
COULD FOLLOW OR DAUGHTER OUT
HERE WHO DID.
AFTER SHE GRADUATES --
GET MARRIED AND SUBSEQUENTLY
SAID WE'VE WE HAVE TWO
GRANDDAUGHTERS [INAUDIBLE]
ARM [INAUDIBLE]
THE WHAT'S WE GOT OUT HERE WE
IMMEDIATELY BECAME INVOLVED IN
THE AND THE MS SOCIETY.
AND OUR I EVEN.
DEVELOPED A OUR CAREGIVER
SUPPORT GROUP WHICH LASTED ABOUT
THREE YEARS YOU CAN'T KEEP
CAREGIVERS COMING.
UP TO TWO MEETINGS BECAUSE THEY
JUST DON'T HAVE THE TIME.
TO DID THAT AS LONG AS AS
POSSIBLE.
AND THEN WE WE KIND OF MADE A
LITTLE MISTAKE LEAH [INAUDIBLE]
WANTED.
TO DO THE BEST BY BY EVERYONE
AND I GET SOME REAL ESTATE SO WE
BOUGHT A HOUSE TOGETHER
[INAUDIBLE]
ARE UNFORTUNATELY.
AT THAT POINT A TIME ALICE.
ACTUALLY STARTED GETTING WHERE
SHE STARRED LOSING THE YOU USE
OF HER LEFT HAND SO AT THAT
POINT SHE COULD NO LONGER
TRANSFER ON THE ROAD.
SO WE WE HAD TO BRING IT HERE
BRINGING CAREGIVERS AND OF WHICH
WHICH I DID AND I WAS STILL ABLE
TO KEEP WORKING BY BY DOING THAT
THAT.
IT WAS NOT A GOOD SITUATION FOR
FOR OUR TOTAL FAMILY DYNAMICS SO
WE HAD.
TO OUR BREAK UP OUR FAMILY
SITUATION AND WE MOVED BACK GOT
INTO APARTMENTS SITUATION WHERE.
ARE WHERE WE'RE STILL LIVING --
TODAY.
OF I WAS ABLE TO FINALLY RETIRE.
OF FOUR YEARS AGO.
AND AT THAT POINT OF TIME I
BECAME A FULL TIME CAREGIVER
[INAUDIBLE]
AND JOB.
ARE I HAVE NO REGRETS --
FORTUNATELY I HAVE MY HEALTH.
OF MY SHRINK SIDE I WAS A FORMER
ATHLETE IN MARINE I'D BEEN ABLE
TO KEEP UP WITH EVERYTHING I
DON'T GET DEPRESSED [INAUDIBLE]
BUT I COULD SURE USE SOME HELP
RIGHT NOW BECKWITH RESPITE
BOTTLED UP BY BOTHER HARM.
ABA IN THE INTEREST OF TIME IF
WE CAN DO ABOUT THAT UP HERE BUT
THANK YOU FOR TELLING US ABOUT
YOUR JOURNEY.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THE JOURNEY
IS REALLY A CALL.
UNIQUE THAT COMMON IN THAT IT
DOESN'T HAPPEN OVERNIGHT IT'S
INVESTING YOU KNOW.
SITUATIONS CHANGED AND
INVALUABLE THE CAREGIVER WITHOUT
EVER ASKING FOR IT OR YOU A DOES
NOT RING IS NEVER THE SENATE
YEAH.
BUT BUT THANK YOU SO MUCH BOB
FOR SHARING ARM AND IT BEGIN
ABOVE THE MOVE FORWARD MATT
OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE OF
QUESTIONS COMMENTS LATER.
ABA SUSAN DEMERITS THAT
ACCOMPANIES THE POLICY DIRECTOR
OF THE ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION
AGREE PARTNER OF THIS
LEGISLATION [INAUDIBLE]
THANK.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE AND
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY --
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN AND
THE COMMITTEE.
FOR AND I WANT TO THANK SANDERS.
WHO CREATED WHO ALLOWED US TO
WORK ON THIS REPORT AND FOR
EVERYONE WHO DID THE TREMENDOUS
STAFF WORK TO PRODUCE IT TODAY?
I'M ON DEADLINE JULY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN HERE WE ARE --
BACK IN --
TWENTY ELEVEN CALIFORNIA DID A
SIMILAR PROCESS TO DEVELOP AND
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE STATE PLAN
AND THERE WERE SIX GOAL AREAS IN
THAT PLAN ONE OF THEM WAS.
ACKNOWLEDGE THE INFORMAL ROLE OF
THE FAMILY CARE GIVER AND TODAY
WE'RE DOING THAT WERE PUBLICLY
ACKNOWLEDGING IT TOOK SEVEN
YEARS BUT WE'RE DOING IT TODAY.
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
I'M IN DONNA'S SLIDES WERE AND I
ALSO WANTED TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE IN THE ROOM KNOWS THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA DID
INTRODUCE --
ATTACKS A CAREGIVER TAX CREDIT
BILL LAST YEAR --
AND WAS A LEADER ON ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT'S CONTAINED
IN THE REPORT AND WE WERE
PLEASED TO WORK WITH THE MS
SOCIETY ON THAT THAT LEGISLATION --
AND DONNA'S OVERVIEW YOU SAW
THAT ONE IN FOUR CALIFORNIA CARE
GIVERS ARE PROVIDING CARE TO
SOMEONE LIVING WITH DEMENTIA --
IN IN OUR STATE TODAY THAT THAT
MEANS ONE POINT SIX MILLION
INDIVIDUALS ARE CAREGIVERS --
IN THIS SLIDE HERE ON THIS IS
ALFORD IN SAN DIEGO.
WHO PROVIDED PARITY Y. THEIR
STORIES TYPICAL SHE HAD TO LEAVE
HER HIGH SCHOOL PILE GT JOB?
EARTH.
AND PANTER HIS RARE EARLY
EIGHTEEN DURING HIS WATCH SO TWO
CAREERS --
WERE CUT SHORT WHICH IN INCLUDED
THERE --
MONTHLY INCOME AS WELL AS I'M
FOR GOING A LOT OF THEIR
RETIREMENT SAVINGS [INAUDIBLE]
BANKS.
TODAY WE HAVE SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
LIVING WITH ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE.
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT NUMBER'S
GOING TO CLIMB.
IN THE TIME THAT OUR NEWEST
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILL BE IN
OFFICE WE HOPE.
BOTH OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
HERE TODAY.
ON IN THIS SLIDE YOU HAVE --
BOB LYNCH SIDE HIS PROVIDING
CARE TO HIS WIFE PAM.
ON SHE IS LIVING WITH YOUNGER
ONSET ALZHEIMER'S AND SHE HAD TO
CUT SHORT HER CAREER AS AN
EXECUTIVE WITH INTEL.
IN SAN JOSE AND IS NOW
PARTICIPATING IN RESEARCH.
I KNOW HER BEEN WOULD BE --
SUFFERING IMPRESSED TEACH THEM
AS HE IS KEEPING CAREER.
A BOAT DURING HIS WHAT.
AND WE HEARD FROM EDEA --
ABOUT THE DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACTS ON AND FROM THE CDC
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL DATA
WE DID CONDUCT --
CAREGIVER --
BURDEN DATA ON CALIFORNIA AND
THIS IS WHAT WE CONCLUDED NOT
SURPRISING.
ON THE MAJORITY ARE WOMEN --
SURPRISINGLY THE MAJORITY DO
HAVE A COLLEGE DEGREE.
ON BUT AS WE'RE HEARING MORE AND
MORE THAT MOST ARE UNDER AGE.
SIXTY FOUR AND THE VAST MAJORITY
ARE IN.
AND IN THE CASE OF ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE AND WE HEARD THIS FROM
YOU TOO ON CAREGIVERS ARE
PROVIDING VERY INTIMATE CARE NOT
SUPERFICIAL CARE SUCH AS MAKING
LUNCH ON THEIR VERY INTIMATELY
INVOLVED IN CAREGIVING.
AND THIS IS LIVE BASS YOU JUST
GRADUATED WITH A MASTER'S IN
PUBLIC HEALTH.
FROM SAN BASS BEAT UNIVERSITY.
AND SHE TOOK TIME OFF BETWEEN
HER PROGRESS GRADUATE SCHOOL
TRIED TO HER GRAND DAUGHTER SO
SHE WOULD BE A MILLENNIAL
CAREGIVER.
AND THEY'RE ARMED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF MILLENNIAL
CAREGIVERS IN OUR STATE.
SO NOW IN TERMS OF THE REPORT WE
AGREE A 100% WITH EVERY
RECOMMENDATION SO WE COULD END
THERE BUT THERE ARE FEW --
I WON THE FLAG IF YOU POLICY
CHANGES THAT.
ON THE ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION
IN PARTICULAR SUPPORTS --
THIS THAT THIS.
NAM ABOUT.
MORE ER VISITS THAN THERE ARE
PEOPLE WITH ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE
SHOULD CONCERN ALL OF US --
THAT IS NOT THE RIGHT PLACE.
I'M TO RECEIVE CARE IT'S VERY
COSTLY TO MEDICARE AND MEDICAID
BUT IT'S OFTEN OUT OF
EXASPERATION FOR A FAMILY
CAREGIVER --
WHO DOESN'T KNOW WHERE TO TURN --
DURING THE NIGHT ON THE WEEKENDS --
AND WE WE THINK IN THE REPORT ON
THE FOCUS ON CARE TRANSITIONS IS
VERY IMPORTANT THIS IS OFTEN
WHERE THIS OCCURS --
BETWEEN LEVELS OF CARE THAT
SOMEBODY.
ON PERHAPS IS AN ASSISTED LIVING
AND THEN AN AMBULANCE IS CALLED
AND THEY GO TO THE HOSPITAL
WHERE THEY'RE AT HOME AND THEY
GO TO THE HOSPITAL --
CAREGIVER TRAINING AND EDUCATION
WHEN THE CAREGIVER IS INFORMED
WHATEVER THE CONDITION IS
WHATEVER THE DURATION OF THE
CARE GIVING WITH --
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE.
AND HEALTH INFORMATION ON THAT
THEY CAN UNDERSTAND WHETHER IT'S
PAMPHLETS ONLINE OR IN PERSON
TRAINING.
ON THIS REALLY HELPS REDUCE ON
HOSPITALIZATIONS I'M AND THEN
WAIT WE FULLY SUPPORT THE
STANDARDIZE CARE GIVER
ASSESSMENT RECOMMENDATION
BECAUSE WORKING STATEWIDE WE SEE
PEOPLE DEPENDING ON WHICH COUNTY
THERE AND THEY'RE ASK DIFFERENT
QUESTIONS WHEN THEY WHEN THEIR
LOVED ONE PROGRESSES. TO A
HIGHER LEVEL OF CARE THEY START
OVER WITH THE WHOLE NOTHER
ASSESSMENT AND MOST OFTEN CARE
GIVERS AREN'T ASSESSED AT ALL.
OBSERVE OTHER POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS WE WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AND ON THE CARE
TRANSITIONS PEAS AND MANY OF YOU
KNOW.
OMINOUS OUR EXPERIENCE WITH THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION THAT --
YOU KNOW SOMEONE MAY NOT BE A
CAREGIVER.
ALL SOMEONE'S HOSPITALIZED AND
SOMEBODY ON FROM OUT OF THE AREA
AN ADULT CHILD BECOMES A
CAREGIVER OVERNIGHTS --
SO CARE.
CARE TRANSITIONS --
REQUIRE VERY SPECIAL FOCUSED
ATTENTION.
AND IN TERMS OF BUDGET CHANGES
ARM THIS IS PAUL IN REDDING
CALIFORNIA AND WE WANT TO BE
SURE THAT --
THE ODD KNOWS THAT CAN BRING
EXTENDS TO LIKE IT'S COULD
ENTITIES TO THE NEP WILL PROVIDE
CARE TO A LOVED ONE ASSISTED
LIVING IN SINGLE VISIT DAILY.
AND ARE MISSING MANAGED CARE
EVEN AND A LICENSE OR A HOSPITAL
SETTING.
I'M SO WERE VERY STRONG STRONG
ON PROPONENTS OF INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED.
OPTIONS AVAILABLE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH A VARIETY OF
CONDITIONS AS WELL AS FOR
CAREGIVERS.
AND EXPANDING RESPITE CARE
OPTIONS CERTAINLY THE CAREGIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS WOULD BE.
ON TOP OF MIND THERE ARE OTHER
RESTED OPTIONS THAT WE'D LIKE TO
SEE EXPANDED AS IN ADDITION TO
THE PROM.
FULLY FUNDING ON THE CAREGIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS AND
STRENGTHENING LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE ONE OF THE THE HARDEST
CALLS THAT WE TAKE ON OUR
HELPLINE IS WHEN.
SOMEONE SAYS AND WE HEAR THIS.
DOZENS OF TIMES A DAY.
BUT WAIT I THOUGHT MEDICARE
COVERED THAT AND WE HAVE TO
EDUCATE SOMEBODY IN CRISIS ABOUT
THE LIMITATIONS OF MEDICARE.
AND QUALIFYING FOR MEDI CAL IF
THAT'S EVEN AN OPTION --
FOR THEM SO THOSE WOULD BE ARE.
THOUGH THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
THE ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION WITH
UNDERSCORE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SUSAN.
UP NEXT AT JUNIOR CASTING
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA WORK AND
FAMILY COALITION.
THANK YOU I'M I'M REALLY EXCITED
AND HAPPY TO BE HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
TASK FORCE.
I WAS SO I AM --
I WORK WITH A STATEWIDE
CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION.
AND THE DIRECTOR THERE'S A
MEMBERS AND STAFF HERE GOING
TODAY.
AND WE ARE KIND OF COLLECTIVE
VISION IS A WORLD WHERE AND THE
COUNTRY IN THE STATE WHERE ALL
PEOPLE HAVE THE TIME RESOURCES
AND SUPPORT SYSTEMS. TO CARE FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES
AND MEANINGFUL LIVES AND I FEEL
LIKE THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THIS REALLY COINCIDE WITH THAT
BECAUSE WE RECENTLY --
INDUCTED ON OF ANTENNAS ON OUR
STERN COMMITTEE WE'VE REALLY --
WANTING TO HAVE PUT SOME MORE
FOCUS IN OUR WORK WHICH IS ON A
WORKPLACE SUPPORT.
FOR WORKERS WHO NEED TO YOU KNOW
BALANCE THEIR WORK AND THEIR
FAMILY LIFE --
AND WE REALLY WANT TO FOCUS IN
ON CARE GIVERS BECAUSE THERE'S
JUST NOT.
ENOUGH OF THEIR ON BOTH
KNOWLEDGE YOU MIGHT CARE GIVERS
REALLY NEED WHICH I THINK THIS
TASK FORCE HAS LAID OUT SOME
REALLY GREAT.
RECOMMENDATIONS AND WE ARE ALSO
DOING A STUDY FOCUSING IN ON
PAID FAMILY LEAVE AND HOW THAT
WORKS OR DOESN'T WORK.
FOR OUR CAREGIVERS AND WHAT ELSE
PEOPLE NEED BECAUSE SOMETIMES
IT'S BAILEY'S SOMETIMES IT'S
LIKE.
YOU KNOW A PREDICTABLE SCHEDULE
ARE THINGS YOU KNOW THAT HOW
PEOPLE BALANCE THEIR LIFE.
I'M SO YOU KNOWS PEOPLE KNOW
THAT CARE GIVING IS REALLY
EXPENSIVE AND TIME CONSUMING AND
EXHAUSTING.
IN I'M WORKING WITH HUMAN IMPACT
PARTNERS ON THE STUDY FOCUSED ON
CARE GIVERS AND WHY THEY'RE NOT
TAKING PAID LEAVE --
ONE OF THE THINGS I LEARNED
RIGHT AWAY EVEN IN JUST DURING
THE OUTREACH IS HOW IT
INCREDIBLY EXHAUSTED.
BOB PEOPLE ARE AND I'VE BEEN
HEARING STORIES WHERE AT THE
BEGINNING OF A CARE GIVER
JOURNEY IS ALSO THE BEGINNING OF
OFTEN A SPIRALING INTO POVERTY
THEY CAN REALLY TURN INTO LONG
TERM FINANCIAL INSECURITY.
OF I WAS ON A PANEL EARLIER THIS --
BEN BARTLETT AND HE TOLD HIS
STORY OF HIS MOTHER LOSING A JOB
BECAUSE OF BECOMING A CARE GIVER.
AND HOW HE REMEMBERS THAT AS
JUST THAT EVERYTHING CHANGED FOR
HIS FAMILY --
INCLUDING EVEN HOMELESS SAYS
LIVING WITH DIFFERENT FAMILY
MEMBERS THIS IS NOT EVEN AN
UNUSUAL STORY ESPECIALLY IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE.
EVERYBODY --
IS FACING SUCH A HOUSING
EVICTION CRISIS IN OTHERS YOU
NAME IT AND THAT'S WHY I LOVE
I'M DOING COALITION WORK BECAUSE
WE'RE VERY FOCUSED IN ON
WORKPLACE POLICIES.
BUT WE ARE PRETTY DIVERSE IN THE
SENSE OF LGBTQ NEW EMIGRANTS
ARMED THEM YOU KNOW ANTI
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE GROUPS.
SO WE ARE A LOT OF GROUPS THAT
DON'T JUST FOCUS ON THIS BUT
REALLY BORING HOW DOES THIS
AFFECT OUR COMMUNITY BECAUSE
EVERYBODY.
IS AFFECTED BY CARE GIVING AND
IT'S YOU KNOW SUCH A KEY.
ISSUE I'M SO JUST AS A QUICK
QUICK REFRESHER ON PAID LEAVE
WHICH IS.
THE A LOT OF PROGRESS TOGETHER
IN THE COALITION WE FOUND WAS
VERY HISTORICALLY PASSED PAID
LEAVE IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWO AND A LOT OF
THE GROUPS WHERE CHILDCARE I
THINK I MET --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ERICA I'M LIKE A
DOVE AT THAT TIME.
A LONG TIME AGO.
IT WAS THAT YOU KNOW REALLY
GREAT GROUP CAME TOGETHER WE
PASS IT WAS HISTORIC PEOPLE USED
TO SAY I MEMBER ON WEST WING
SOME EPISODES SOMEBODY BECAUSE A
HUG THEM WILL HAVE PAID FAMILY
LEAVE.
LIKE THAT WOULD NEVER HAPPEN
EVER IN THE COUNTRY AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TALKING WE JUST HAD A
SENATE HEARING TALKING ABOUT
DOING AND WE HOPE THE RIGHT WAY
NOT EATING INTO SOCIAL SECURITY.
THE WE'RE LOOKING AT HAVING AND
THAT'S A LINE THAT SEEMS
IMMINENT THAT AT SOME POINT SOON
AS WE WELL.
ARM IN MEANWHILE YOU KNOW SEVEN
DIFFERENT STATES HAVE IT SO HE
LEAVING CALIFORNIA THAT WAS JUST
A BENEFIT IT IS NOT A RIGHT THAT
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT IT
PROVIDES A WAGE REPLACEMENT.
WHEN YOU GO OUT SO WHAT DONNA
TOUCHED ON EARLIER IN THAT 40%
OF PEOPLE CAN BE LEFT OUT THAT
MEANS YOU CAN LITERALLY PAY INTO
THIS?
STI YOU COVERED BY PAID LEAVE
FOR EITHER CARE GIVING OR
BONDING WITH A NEW CHILD BUT NOT
BE COVERED BY ONE OF THE LAWS
THAT PROTECT YOUR JOB.
THIS IS BEEN LIKE WE HAVE
INTRODUCED AND RELIGIOUS ARENA
TRUTH LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
EXTEND OUR PROTECTION TO PARENTS
AND CAREGIVERS OR WE SPLIT THEM
UP OR WE PUT THEM TOGETHER AGAIN
IN A JUST TRYING IT.
ALL DIFFERENT WAYS THAT HAS HAD
A HUGE AMOUNT OF JUST LAST YEAR
ACTUALLY PATH. FOR THE FIRST
TIME I'M MORE JOB PROTECTION FOR
PARENT NEW PARENTS WE REALLY OF
NO FROM ALL THE STUDIES THAT
CAME OUT.
I SIX YEARS SEVEN YEARS AFTER
PAVE THE PAST WE LEARNED.
FROM RUTH MILKMAN AND EILEEN
APPLEBAUM I'M A STUDY ON PAY
LEAVING CALIFORNIA HOW IMMENSE
THE BENEFITS WERE.
LONGER BREASTFEEDING --
MORE DADS TAKING BONDING TIME OF
ECONOMIC SECURITY FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO TOOK IT BUT THAT SAME
STUDIES SHOWED US THAT IT DOES
NOT WORK FOR EVERYBODY EQUALLY.
AND THAT'S OUR PROBLEM IN
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME NEW
IMMIGRANT LOS ANGELES COUNTY FOR
SOME REASON SUPER LOW AWARENESS.
ALL WE DID A A FIELD POLL THAT
SHOWED 36% AND EVEN LOWER AMONG
THE GROUPS I JUST MENTIONED.
SO THEY'RE A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT
STUDIES THAT RANGE BETWEEN
THIRTY SIX OR 46% BUT THAT'S
PRETTY LOW FOR ABOUT YOU KNOWS A
FUNDS.
THE MOST OF US PAN TO WHO SO ONE
OF OUR FIRST HOUSE IN THE
COALITION WAS. TO GET ON SOME
FUNDING IN YOU KNOW WITH EASY DO
SOME.
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH WE THINK
THAT HOUSE THAT THAT'S BEEN A
REALLY GREAT START BUT IT HAS TO
GO FURTHER.
INTO SOME OF THE I'M IN A KIND
OF MORE COMMUNITY OUTREACH THE
OTHER ISSUE IS A FEAR OF
RETALIATION.
LOSING YOUR JOB WE REALLY NEED
TO EXTEND JOB PROTECTION --
TO CAREGIVERS WHEN THEY TAKE
TIME OFF BECAUSE HEAPING YOUR
JOB -- FOR
WORKING CAREGIVERS IS THAT HE
LOSING EVERYTHING OUT SO WE'RE
VERY MUCH WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION OF ALL OF THE
SUPPORT THAT WOULD MAKE
PAINFULLY WORK BETTER --
WE'VE DONE SOME THINGS LIKE
EXTEND THE WAGE REPLACEMENT WE
WANT TO SEE IF THAT'S WORKING IS
THAT ENOUGH IS THE NEED TO BE
MORE.
A COUPLE OF CITIES HAVE IT MADE
FULLY PAID PAID LEAVE WE'RE
HOPING BERKELEY EVEN IF IT'S
JUST AN EXAMPLE.
WILL DO THIS FOR CAREGIVERS TO
SO WE CAN SEE HOW DOES THAT HELP
WHEN PEOPLE CAN GET THEIR FULL
PAY.
SOME.
SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT -- ONE
OF THE OTHER THINGS IN TERMS OF
OUR KIND OF RECOMMENDATIONS WITH
WHERE TO GO NEXT ARE.
WORKING ON THOSE --
WORKING WITH US AND THE EDT WE
WOULD LOVE TO SEE.
BEING MORE CONNECTED TO THE TASK
FORCE IN SOME WAY --
SO THAT THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
ARE HEARD BY THE THE THE BECAUSE
THEY CAN DO A LOT --
IN TERMS OF HELPING US GET THIS
OUT TO THE COMMUNITY --
TOGETHER EDUCATE PEOPLE ON THEIR
RIGHTS -- WE
ALSO DO TRAININGS --
OF CAREGIVERS AND PARENTS ON THE
RIGHTS OF THE OTHER THING TOO IS
THAT HE LEAVES HAVING A REALLY
BIG MOMENT.
AND WE NEED TO REALLY TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT IT'S IN THE
PRESS.
RUBIO IS INTRODUCING A BILL BUT
WE ABSOLUTELY WANT TO TAKE THIS
MOMENT AND STAND FOR THE
STRONGEST BEST MOST INCLUSIVE.
HAY LEAVE THAT WE CAN AND NOT IT
WOULD ONLY BENEFIT PARENTS ABOUT
THAT PARENTS ARE NEEDED.
TO AND NOT BENEFIT THEM VERY
WELL THINK THE GROOVY A BILL
THAT WOULD ALSO CUTTING INTO
SOCIAL SECURITY WHICH IS
FOUNDATIONAL.
TO EVERYTHING.
SO WE ABSOLUTELY --
I INVITE EVERYBODY TO STAND WITH
US BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH WE'RE
CALIFORNIA AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO PASS STRONGER LAWS WE ARE
GONNA REALLY NEED TO STAND WITH
OUR SISTER COALITIONS AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
A TAKING THAT TIME BECAUSE THERE
THE CAREGIVER ANYBODY WHO'S BEEN
IN A WORKING COMMITTEE KNOWS
THERE'S THAT ONE PERSON THAT
DOES ALL THE WORK.
CARE GIVERS LIKE MY CO WORKERS
TALKING THINKING YOU KNOW HOW
THAT I'M SITUATION WHERE THERE
THE ONE EVEN AND I'M DOING A
LITTLE HELPING WITH THE RESEARCH
WE DID RECENTLY I HEARD THAT
AGAIN AND AGAIN.
I'M THE ONE PERSON BUT I'VE GOT
SIBLINGS ABOUT THIS ABOUT THAT.
IF WE'RE LOOKING AT PAID LEAVE
THE WAY DAD STARTED TAKING LEAVE
MORE.
IT'S NOT THAT I I THINK IT DOES
NEED TO BE A CHOICE BUT AT THE
SAME TIME WE NEED TO CREATE THAT
CULTURE WHERE IT SPREADING
FURTHER.
AND IF YOU ARE A FAMILY MEMBER
EVEN FAR AWAY YOU TAKE CAN TAKE
SOMETIME.
YOU CAN GIVE THE PART OF THE
RESPITE FOR THAT PERSON THAT IS
EXHAUSTED IN DEALING WITH HEALTH
ISSUES OF THEIR OWN.
SO THOSE ARE OUR INNER
CONDITIONS AND I REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO THEM CONTINUING TO
COLLABORATE HOPEFULLY.
THEY KILL YOU THANK YOU.
I'M HOOKED.
UP NEXT WITH AMANDA STEELE
DEPUTY PAUSED POLICY DIRECTOR
SEIU LOCAL.
TWENTY FIFTEEN THANK YOU AND I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
FOR HAVING US HERE TODAY --
THIS TASK FORCES. FOR ME I'M
WORKING AT A YOU KNOW.
WE REPRESENT OVER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND I JUST US WORKERS WHICH
IS OUR OWN IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA
SO.
I'M REALLY GRATEFUL THAT THIS
WORK IS BEING DONE IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AND I'M EXCITED TO BE
HERE.
UNTO YOU GO TO THE CAN.
I'M I APOLOGIZE FOR ALL THE
NUMBERS BUT I AM A RESEARCHER
HURT SOMEHOW I I LIKE NUMBERS --
BUT I'LL TRY AND MAKE IT A
LITTLE BIT MORE INTERESTING SO I
JUST WANTED TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT ON THE HOME CARE LANDSCAPE
HEARING PORN YOU.
WERE HEARING A LOT ABOUT ON THE
ON THE FAMILY.
RIVER IN THE STATE.
AND THEY ALSO A WHOLE OTHER ON
SITE.
PAID THEM CARE WORKERS ON YOU
KNOW WE HAVE OUR PRIVATE AGENCY
WHO ARE WERE BIRDS ARE.
WE DOING HOME HEALTH WORKED.
ON YOU WE HAVE ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND SEVEN THOUSAND OF THOSE
HERBS HEARING CALIFORNIA AND
THOSE ARE MOSTLY.
ON PEOPLE THAT HAVE THE MEANS TO
A OUT POCKET FOR A HOME BECOMING
THEIR HOME AND TAKE CARE OF
SERVICES PROGRAM WHICH IS FUNDED
THROUGH MEDI CAL HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THOSE ARE THE WORKERS THAT WE
REPRESENT ON THERE'S OVER FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND OF THOSE
WORKERS HEARING* CARRIED.
FOR ABOUT OFTEN MEANS THERE IS
AN ABSENCE OF THE BILL FACILITY
HUGE WORKFORCE.
AND I'LL JUST KIND OF TOUCH ON
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN SAID.
IN THAT YOU KNOW THIS WORKFORCE
IS LARGELY WOMEN MINORITIES LOW
WAGE WORKERS SO I'M IT'S THE
POPULATION AND DIET AND REALLY
IT IS IT'S A VERY UNIQUE
POPULATION AND I'M IN ITS
REFLECTIVE ALSO OF YOU KNOW THAT
THE UNPAID.
AT FAMILY CAREGIVERS THAT WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT EARLIER.
SO I AGES SIZE HAS GROWN A LOT
AT HOME IT IT'S GROWN I'M FROM
ABOUT CARING FOR FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE TO OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND IN THE PAST TEN
YEARS.
WE EXPECTED TO KEEP GROWTH IN
OUR PEOPLE ARE ADRIN OF COURSE
AND PEOPLE NEED THE SURPLUS FUND.
ON THIS IS A PROGRAM SERVING
PEOPLE AND I AM.
OUR LOW INCOME THERE AND MEDI
CAL ON MANY OF THEM ARE ALSO
FAMILY CAREGIVERS.
AND THERE IS ABOUT AND THERE'S
OVER ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS FROM
FEDERAL AND STATE FUNDING THAT
ONE INTO LARGE SAYS PROGRAM I'M
WHICH OBVIOUSLY IS A TON OF
MONEY -- BUT
THIS PROGRAM IS STILL IT STILL
FACES CHALLENGES ALL THE TIME
BECAUSE IT'S ALWAYS GROWING AND
THE NEEDS ARE JUST GONNA
CONTINUE.
TO SO I JUST WANTED.
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT ON
THE HOME CARE CRISIS THAT WERE
KIND OF FACING RIGHT NOW AND
PEOPLE REALLY NEED HOME CARE.
AND AND AND I THINK THAT THERE
IS A LITTLE BIT OF A PUSH TO
MOVE AWAY FROM INSTITUTIONAL
CARE AND TWO MORE HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES SO.
YOU KNOW WE ALL KNOW THAT THE
POPULATION OF PEOPLE OVER SIXTY
FIVE IS IS GROWING AT A REALLY
RAPID RATE SO.
THERE'S EXPECTED TO BE ABOUT
NINE MILLION I'M PEOPLE OVER
SIXTY FIVE BENEATH ME SO WILL
ARE THE PEOPLE AMERICA NEEDS
SOME TYPE OF LONG TERM CARE.
SO ON MEAN IF THE HOME CARE
INDUSTRY WORD EXPANDED OVER ALL
THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE SOME SORT
OF CARE LIMITATION FOR THOSE
REALLY THE PEOPLE THAT.
I'M WOULD NEED SOME TYPE OF HELP
ON THIS IN THEIR HOME.
WE NEED AT LEAST SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND UNITS AND AS MUCH AS
THREE MEN AND ADDITIONAL HOME
CARE WORKERS DINNERS BY TWELVE
THIRTY TO MEET THAT THAT DEMAND.
AND AND RIGHT NOW THE THE
INDUSTRY IS JUST NOT ATTRACTING
WORKERS BECAUSE THE WAGES AND
THE BENEFITS THAT'S A VERY HARD
JOB IT'S A VERY DEMANDING JOB.
ON YOU KNOW AS WAS TALK ABOUT BY
OTHER ON PEOPLE ON THESE PANELS
THAT YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE LEAVING
THEIR FULL TIME JOB ARE THERE
OTHER LUCRATIVE ABOUT WORK TO
TAKE CARE SOMEONE ELSE AND THEN
IT PUTS THEM AND YOU KNOW ABOUT
FINANCIAL SUCH.
THERE'S A LOT OF ISSUES THAT
COME COME ALONG WITH TAKING ON
THIS ROLE.
SO ON THIS --
WASN'T SO.
DOES THIS STATUS FROM TWENTY
FIFTEEN SO ON ITS LITTLE BIT
OUTDATED BUT THIS IS JUST
HIGHLIGHTING THE THE LOW WAGES
THAT HOME CARE WORKERS.
ARE FACING COMPARED TO OTHER ON
EMPLOYEES OPPORTUNITIES AND A
LOT OF HOME CARE WORKERS ARE ARE
THAN THAT SO.
EITHER LIVING AND BLOWING THEM
HOUSEHOLDERS RECEIVING PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE THAT SOUTH NOT ONLY A
BOUTIQUE AIRSOFT GUN.
THAT IS ON MEDI CAL OR AND IS
RELYING ON THESE PROGRAMS BUT AS
A HOME CARE WORKER MANY OF THEM
ARE ALSO RELYING ON THOSE ON
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS TO
GET BY.
SO THOSE IDEA THE NEXT SLIDE.
SO YOUR VISITORS GOING INTO MORE
OF THE ODD ON IN CALIFORNIA
ABOUT 22% OF HOME CARE WORKERS
ARE RELYING ON FOOD STAMPS.
AND 22% ARE LIVING OUT OUR BELOW
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
SO THIS IS A HUGE PROBLEM AND
AND YOU KNOW A LOT OF HOME CARE
WORKERS ARE ARE AT MINIMUM WAGE --
A LOT OF THEM DON'T RECEIVE
HEALTH INSURANCE.
AND ON IT YOU KNOW IT'S
DIFFICULT AND IT'S IT'S A VERY
DIFFICULT HOME PROGRAM AND A GUN
YOU KNOW WE AS A UNION WE WE
BARGAIN AT THE COUNTY LEVEL AND
THERE'S FIFTY SIX COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO EACH
COUNTY IS VERY DIFFERENT FROM
ANOTHER ON AND HOW WILLING.
THEY ARE TO INVEST IN I JUST US
AND HOME CARE WORK ARMS SO YOU
KNOW IT'S HARD TO REALLY GET
THIS WORKFORCE TO BE RECOGNIZES
A PROFESSIONAL REALLY VALUED.
AND GROUP OF WORKERS THINK
THERE'S THIS PERCEPTION THAT'S
MAYBE STARTING TO CHANGE NOW
THAT.
HOME CARE WORKERS ARE JUST
ALMOST LIKE A HOUSE KEEPER DOING
HOME HOMEMAKING WORK AND THAT'S
JUST NOT TRUE ON THEIR DOING SO
MUCH MORE THAN THAT THEY'RE
KEEPING PEOPLE SAFE IN THEIR
HOMES I'M A LOT OF THEM ARE
DOING MEDICAL TASK SO.
I THINK WE HAVE TO GET TO THE
POINT WHERE THIS PROFESSION IS
REALLY RECOGNIZED FOR WHAT IT IS
AND THE VALUE THAT IT BRINGS TO
OUR SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITY.
SO JUST GOING INTO THAT --
THERE'S SOME STATS THAT SAY AND
I JUST US THE ANNUAL TURNOVER IS
AS HIGH AS 33% WHICH MEANS THAT.
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND CONSUMERS ARE OR
RECIPIENTS THAT ARE RECEIVING
CARE HAVE TO FIND A NEW PROVIDER.
EVERY YEAR.
AND AS AN OF THE CALL.
I'M HURDLE OF TURNOVER BIRD A
LONG TERM CARE WORKER IS ABOUT.
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOCTORS
DEMAND AND WHAT THE THERE AND
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN CARE THAT
THE A HUGE CALL [INAUDIBLE]
BILLIARDS
RE WITH ALL OF THOSE
ON HERE IS [INAUDIBLE]
EMOTIONAL [INAUDIBLE]
WORK I'M IT'S TAKING THEM YOU
KNOW AWAY FOR MORE LUCRATIVE
CAREERS IT'S ALSO HARD TO
ATTRACT PEOPLE ESPECIALLY PEOPLE
THAT ARE NOT FAMILY CAREGIVERS
ON THERE'S A HIGH NEED.
FOR ON PEOPLE TO TAKE CARE OF
OTHER PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT
NECESSARILY AYE YOUR FAMILY SO
IT'S REALLY HARD TO GET PEOPLE
INTO THOSE ROLES.
AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE OR
AGAIN THAT WE'RE CREATING THOSE
QUALITY JOBS THAT ARE MOSTLY FOR
WOMEN PEOPLE OF COLOR OF FOREIGN
BORN WORKERS.
AND THEN AGAIN --
IT ALL IT ALL GOES BACK TO
MAKING IT A STABLE PROFESSION
THAT'S RECOGNIZED ON RAISING THE
WAGES AND PROVIDING GOOD
BENEFITS OFFER HOME CARE WORKERS
I AM.
GRANTED IN INDUSTRY SHORTAGE IS
BY.
HAVING ENHANCED ANY CAREER LOOK
BETTER THOUGH.
AND APPARENTLY IT'S NO.
NO SIR BIG HERE PAN FOR I'M HOME
WORK BUT I'M REALLY ARE SENATE
CREATING OR A TRAIN OPERATES
NEEDS FOR HOME CARE WORKERS.
IN SOME MENTIONED HAVING THEM BE
MORE PART OF INTEGRATED CARE
TEAM AND BE MORE INVOLVED WITH
YOU KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
THEIR CONSUMERS CARE AND TALKING
TO THE DOCTORS AND NO WHEN IS
THOSE ARE ALL IMPORTANT.
IS THAT THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE HAPPEN IN THE HOME TOGETHER
THE WRAP UP ASSURE YOU I'M THAT
OUR THAT I I AM THAT'S ACTUALLY
MY LAST SLIDE SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
AMANDA.
OF THEM AND THEN WE'LL MOVE ON
TO CRISTINA BASS HAMILTON
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR.
UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS OF
AMERICA ASK YOU LOCAL THREE NINE
THIRTY I END UP BEFORE YOU BEGIN
TO SEE THAT.
ALSO EXTEND THE AB EXTEND OUR
THANKS TO YOUR EXACT DIRECTOR
DOUG MORRIS SERVED ON THE TASK
FORCES I'LL BE REALLY APPRECIATE
THANK YOU AT YES --
ACTUALLY HE IS SORRY HE CAN BE
HERE TODAY WE HAVE OUR
INTERNATIONAL CONVENTION IN
BOSTON.
SO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COME LONGER.
A DOVE IF I HAVE ANY AYE.
WANT TO ECHO EVERYTHING EVERYONE
SAID DOESN'T LIKE THE EASIEST
PAMELA BEYOND HERE RIGHT
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAH WHO.
I'M ACTUALLY WHAT I WILL SAY IS
THIS.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING
IS THE CRISIS OF BIRD BEING
PARDON THE PUN BECAUSE I'M.
THANK YOU VERY FELLOW RIGHT NOW
BURBANK LITERALLY IN A SYSTEM
[INAUDIBLE]
I DON'T [INAUDIBLE]
CHAOS AND WHEN A WHAT YOU WOULD
CALL IN NON [INAUDIBLE]
STATUS OF SYSTEMS RIGHT
BESTSELLERS.
LITERALLY NO PRODUCT OF BRAIN
LACK OF VALUE OF THIS TYPE OF
LABOR HISTORICALLY [INAUDIBLE]
AND COMING OUT OF YOU KNOW NINES
OF TIME IN WHICH THIS TYPE OF
LABOR WAS DONE I'M PAID
UNRECOGNIZED AT HOME.
AND I WAS SIMPLY NOT A TOPIC OF
PUBLIC DISCUSSION AND WAS SIMPLY
A SOMETHING THAT FAMILY MEMBERS
ALL USUALLY FEMALE DID AND PART
OF THEIR EXPECTATION OF SOCIETAL
ROLES.
AND SO WE NOW LIVE IN A
DIFFERENT WORLD WHERE PEOPLE ARE
LIVING LONGER AND FOLKS DELUDE
WORKING OUTSIDE THE HOME.
AND WE HAVE A CRISIS BECAUSE HOW
DO YOU DEAL WITH THAT HOW DO YOU
HAVE A SYSTEM.
WHERE NON CURRENTLY EXISTS
EXCEPT FOR THIS INFORMAL --
SYSTEM OR NON SYSTEM.
SO.
OUT OF CHAOS WE NEED TO BIRTH
SOMETHING NEW AND WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SOMETHING NEW
BECAUSE REVENUE GOVERNOR.
AND THAT NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE A
GOVERNOR WE CONSTELLATION OF OF
FACTORS WE'VE GOT THE THREAT OF
LOSING MEDICAID FUNDING WHICH IS
JUST A QUESTION OF TIME AND ALL
OF THIS IS FUNDED BY MEDICAID
[INAUDIBLE]
WE'VE GOT.
THE CRISIS WITHIN IHS US ITSELF
WHICH IS THAT THEY COUNTIES THE
SHARING OF COSTS OF I JUST AS IF
YOU KNOW ANYONE WHO WORKS AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL.
THEY WILL TELL YOU THERE'S A
HUGE PROBLEM WITH COUNTY IS NOT --
GETTING.
ENOUGH MONEY FROM THE STATE TO
COVER THE COSTS IN ITS JUST AS
ONGOING OUR PROBLEM THAT IS A
GROUP REACHING WHAT I WOULD SAY
A PAX RIGHT NOW --
AND WE'VE GOT THIS LACK OF
WORKERS IT AS AMENDED JUST THAT
PEOPLE NEED TO BE RECRUITED TO
DO THIS WORK BUT WHY SHOULD THEY
DO THAT WHEN THEY COULD GO WORK
AT MCDONALDS.
AND HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY LESS
STRESS AND GET PAID THE SAME
AMOUNT OF MONEY.
SO WE'VE GOT A PROBLEM BUT OUT
OF PROBLEM IS OPPORTUNITY TO DO
SOMETHING NEW AND SIGNIFICANT
AND DIFFERENT [INAUDIBLE]
AND FOR THE SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF YOU W. WE SEE THE ONLY
SOLUTION TO THIS CRISIS BEING.
THE CREATION OF A SOCIAL
INSURANCE MODEL BECAUSE WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED THROUGH STUDYING
PRIVATE INDUSTRY AND PRIVATE
INSURANCE.
IS THAT IT IS SIMPLY NOT A
PROFITABLE PRODUCT NOT ENOUGH
PEOPLE BUY THE PRODUCT TO OFFSET
THE RISK FOR THE PEOPLE WHO USE
IT.
SO FROM INSURANCE PERSPECTIVE
UNLESS YOU MANDATE BUT EVERYBODY
BY IT AND WE ALL KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THAT EXPERIMENT
BICU YEARS AGO.
OF OR RECENTLY OF YOU MANDATE
EITHER YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE
MANDATING EVERYBODY BY THE
INSURANCE OR YOU'RE APPROACHING
IT FROM A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
ANGLE WHICH IS A SOCIAL
INSURANCE MODEL WHICH I WOULD
ARGUE IS BEHIND.
THE SUCCESS OF THOSE PROGRAMS
THAT WE DO HAVE LIKE SOCIAL
SECURITY AND MEDICARE PEOPLE.
PEOPLE DON'T EVEN REALIZE
THEY'RE PAYING INTO IT THERE IS
NOW A SOCIETAL EXPECTATION THAT
THIS IS WHAT YOU WORK TOWARD AN
URN AND HAVE. TO EXPECT AS YOU
GET OLDER AND WE NEED TO SEE THE
SAME THING HAPPENED IN THIS
ARENA AND FRANKLY LIKE SUSAN
SAID MOST PEOPLE THINK IT'S
ALREADY THE CASE IT'S JUST
ACTUALLY NOT.
SO WE'VE GOT TO FIX THAT.
AND IF THIS IS AN OVERWHELMING --
ISSUE DON'T GET ME WRONG IT'S
NOT LIKE THERE'S THIS YOU KNOW
THERE'S LIKE ONE PAGE HERE'S THE
ANSWER WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE IT OUT AND WARY.
NO WORKING WITH A LOT OF FOLKS
IN THE ROOM ON ON DOING THE HARD
WORK OF THAT.
SO I THINK OUT OF CRISIS COMES
OPPORTUNITY AND THIS COMMITTEE
CAN PLAY A REALLY IMPORTANT ROLE
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT A SEXY ISSUE.
THIS ISN'T SOMETHING PEOPLE LIKE
PARKING A I IT IT'S A CRISIS
THAT GOES IN ISOLATION IN ON
RECOGNIZED AND FRANKLY I'M
SHOCKED THAT MORE.
A PEOPLE RUNNING FOR OFFICE
DON'T TALK ABOUT IT BECAUSE I
WOULD THINK THIS CROSSES EVERY.
DAM AGE GROUP DEMOGRAPHIC YOU
NAME IT PEOPLE NEED TO START
TALKING ABOUT IT.
AND SO LET ME JUST LEAVE IT WITH
THIS WE BELIEVE THAT THE ANSWER
IS THE CREATION OF A SOCIAL
INSURANCE MODEL.
WE WANT TO WORK WITH --
ALL OUR LEGISLATIVE A CHAMPIONS
TO DO THIS AND WITH OUR OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO DO THIS.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY I WOULD
SAY ONCE IN A GENERATION RIGHT
NOW TO DO WE HAVE A WINDOW OF
OPPORTUNITY AND AND IF WE DON'T
THEN.
SHAME ON US.
MAY I ALSO JUST SAY ONE LAST
THING THE ONE THING THAT THE
STATE CAN DO LEGISLATIVELY TO
ADDRESS.
THE WRECK IT ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT'S IN THE
TASK FORCE REPORT.
IS THE FACT THAT PARENT AND
SPOUSE.
I JUST AS PROVIDERS SAID THIS IS
PROVIDERS WHO CARE FOR THE CHILD
OR A SPOUSE.
ARE NOT ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
MEDICARE OR SOCIAL SECURITY OR
DO NOT AND DO NOT QUALIFY FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE THAT IS
AN IMMEDIATE.
POLICY PROBLEM THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED BECAUSE YOU COULD
LITERALLY WORK YOUR WHOLE ADULT
LIFE AND I JUST SAYS.
AND HAVE ZERO WHEN YOU RETIRE
AND WE ALL KNOW SOCIAL SECURITY
IS NOT MUCH TO BEGIN WITH BUT
YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE THAT.
AND IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PREVENTING THE IMPOVERISHMENT OF
CAREGIVERS FAMILY CARRIERS THAT
IS THE NUMBER ONE POLICY
PERSCRIPTION THAT I WOULD OFFER
THE PROBLEM IS.
THAT THE MEDICARE SOCIAL
SECURITY ISSUES A FEDERAL ISSUE
SO THE CHANCES OF THAT GETTING
FIXED.
OUR ABOUT AS GOOD AS MY CHANCE
OF FLOATING OUT OF THIS ROOM.
BUT THAT'S NOT GONNA BE TRUE FOR
ALL WAYS IN THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE ISSUE ACTUALLY CAN BE
ADDRESS ON THE STATE LEVEL SO WE
DO WANT TO WORK WITH OTHER
ADVOCATES AND WITH THE COMMITTEE
ON THAT AS WELL SO LET ME JUST
LEAVE IT AT THAT.
THINK [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
AND WE WILL AND THE RESPONDENT
PANEL THE DOCTOR NINA.
Y. THEIR HEART WELL YOU KNOW WE
WERE HIGHER WELL BUT THEY ARE P.
CALIFORNIA.
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND SO
ABSOLUTELY DELIGHTED TO BE HERE
TODAY.
THROUGH THE END OF ALMOST A FOR
YOUR JOURNEY.
ARM WE BEGAN THIS EFFORT WORKING
WITH COMMISSIONER AROUND AT THE
END OF FIVE YEAR FIVE YEAR
TWENTY THIRTEEN TO INTRODUCE THE
TASK FORCE LEGISLATION.
AS SHE SAID THE GOV YOU DOWN
WITH THAT ONE BACK TO THE WELL.
ON INTRODUCED AS A RESOLUTION
[INAUDIBLE]
IF PASSED YOU OVERWHELMINGLY AND
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND THE
ERROR P. AND ARCHED ON STEPS AND
AND HERE WE ARE.
I'M I JUST WONDERING KNOWLEDGE
THE TASK FORCE'S WELL ALTHOUGH I
WASN'T A MEMBER.
I PARTICIPATED IN MOST OF THE
MEETINGS AND I JUST WANT TO SAY
WE REALLY APPRECIATE OF THE
PROCESS AS WELL AS THE TASK
FORCE.
FORCES OPENNESS TO OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS [INAUDIBLE]
ARM.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
WORK WITH OUR PARTNERS ON THE
TASK FORCE AS WELL AS IN THE
ROOM.
AND SACRAMENTO AND THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. TO REALLY MAKE REAL
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS SO THAT
THIS IS NOT JUST ANOTHER REPORT
THAT SITS ON THE SHELF.
AND THANKS TO ARM.
THE OFFER OF OUR STATE DIRECTOR
NANCY MCPHERSON HERE HERE P. AS
WE SAID BEFORE WILL BE HOSTING.
STRATEGY SESSION ON LATER THIS
SUMMER SIR PUT TOGETHER CAMPAIGN
PLANS AND ACTIONABLE.
ON ACTIONABLE LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS THAT WE WILL BRING
FORTH IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN SO I JUST WANNA
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE REALLY
RESUME RESONATED WITH A A RP.
AND I WILL SAY THAT EVERY.
EVERY SINGLE RECOMMENDATION ON
HERE.
DOES ONLINE WITH A A RP POLICY
ON WITH THEIR SOME THERE REALLY
FOR US RISE TO THE FOR AND
REALLY NUMBER --
ONE KRISTIN YOU JUST TALKED
ABOUT IT WAS A TOPIC OF LDS US
FINANCING.
ARM A RP YOU DO W. RASPING SEIU
AND SEVERAL INDIVIDUALS IN THIS
ROOM ARE MEMBERS OF A PART OF A
TWENTY TWO MEMBER.
ALLIANCE CALLED THE FELT THE
CALIFORNIA HE AGING AND
DISABILITY ALLIANCE.
AND WE ARE SAT ON A ROCK WORSE A
LONG TERM STRATEGY TO REALLY
MAKE LONG TERM SO. TO MAKE LONG
TERM SUPPORTS AND SERVICES MORE
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE FOR A
LOT MORE CALIFORNIANS AND I DO
WANNA CALL OUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA.
WHO PLAYED AN IMPORTANT PART IN
OUR FIRST WIN WHICH MAY NOT
SOUND LIKE MUCH?
BUT IT WAS A BUDGET REQUEST TO
GET THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
INTERVIEW SURVEY WAS THREE
MILLION DOLLARS.
ON TO START COLLECTING DATA ON
NEED FOR AN ACCESS TO LONG TERM
CARE OF LONG TERM SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
WE HAD NOTHING.
YOU CAN'T PLAN FOR SAY ALL LONG
TERM CARE INSURANCE PROGRAM IF
YOU DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY NEED.
ARM AND WERE WERE COMING TO A
POINT WHERE WE'RE GONNA HAVE AS
MANY PEOPLE OVER SIXTY HAS
PEOPLE UNDER NINETEEN AND STATE
THE STATE NEEDS TO GET SERIOUS
AND THANKFULLY.
NO.
LEGISLATORS LIKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA AND OTHER MEMBERS OF ONE
OF THE LEGISLATURE AS WELL AS
THE ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZES
AND THIS BUDGET REQUEST GOT
THROUGH THE FIRST.
SO WE STAND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CAN CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
LEGISLATORS AGAIN AS WELL AS THE
ALLIANCE ON THIS [INAUDIBLE]
FROM.
I DO WANT TO ALSO TALK A BIT
ABOUT THE CARE GIVER TAX CREDIT
WHICH WE PLAYED A ROLE IN IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ARM WE WORKED
WITH OUTSIDE MURZA MESSED
SOCIETY AND I THINK SOME OTHER
FOLKS IN THE ROOM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA WITH THE ARTHUR.
AND UNFORTUNATELY DIED IN A
CERTAIN COMMITTEE BUT WE WILL
LOOK FORWARD TO REINTRODUCING
OUT AGAIN ESPECIALLY AS WE'RE
WAITING FOR THIS LONG TERM CARE
FINANCING MEASURE WHICH WILL
TAKE SOME TIME TO BUILD UP.
WE NEED TO HAVE SOME KIND OF
INTERIM MEASURE TO HEALTH CARE
GIVERS.
COVER THE COST OF FAMILY
CAREGIVING.
AUTUMN I DON'T THINK THIS HAS
BEEN MENTIONED YET TODAY BUT A A
RP RESEARCH FROM.
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE COST OF CARE
GIVING.
SHOWED THAT THE AVERAGE FAMILY
CAREGIVER FOR AND AN ADULT AND
ADDED THREE WHO IS CARING FOR
ANY ADULT WITH A DISABILITY.
IT'S SPENDING ON AVERAGE NEARLY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
OUT OF POCKET.
AND IF THEY ARE CARING FOR A
LOVED ONE WITHOUT SOME ROOMS.
IT'S OVER TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR.
VERY FEW PEOPLE CAN SAY FOR THAT.
VERY FEW PEOPLE EVEN HAVE THE
MEANS TO SAVE FOR THAT AND ONLY
ABOUT 5% OF CALIFORNIANS EVEN
HAVE LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE.
THAT REALLY HIGHLIGHTS WHY WE
NEED.
SOME KIND OF HEALTH LONG TERM
CARE FINANCING MEASURE AS WELL
HAS JUST TAX CREDIT THE LEARNED
MENTIONED.
PAID FAMILY LEAVE IS ANOTHER I
DON'T TRY TO GO QUICKLY TO
RESPECT TIME HERE --
AS GENO'S ACT PAID FAMILY LEAVE
AS A NATIONAL A OR P. PRIORITY
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH.
ALL THE WORK OF THE THE WORKING
FAMILY COALITION ON THE SURVEY
THAT CHEN YOU REFERENCED.
AND WE'RE REALLY HOPING THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN FINALLY.
GETS TO THE POINT WHERE IT
INTRODUCES AND PASSES AND SIGNS
LEGISLATION THAT ADDS JOB
PROTECTIONS FOR THOSE WHO TAKE
PAID FAMILY LEAVE WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT IS.
ALL A BIG HINDRANCE TO PEOPLE
EVEN TAKING LEAVE RICHARD AS SHE
NOTED WE'VE RECENTLY SEEN AN
INCREASE IN THE WAGE REPLACEMENT
RATE.
THAT JUST CAME IN THE SURE
THAT'LL HELP A BET.
BUT IF FOLKS WORKING FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES CANNOT THAT'S UNDER
FIFTY OF OUR PEOPLE WORKING FOR
EMPLOYERS WITH FIFTY OR FEWER
EMPLOYEES.
IF YOU CANNOT BE GUARANTEED THAT
ARE GONNA HAVE A JOB TO GO BACK.
TO AT YOU TAKE PAID FAMILY LEAVE
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO TAKE.
ARMS SO WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT AND WE STILL HAVE
THAT THE READY TO HELP WITH THAT.
AND WE ALSO SUPPORT BEYOND
MEASURE HIM BERKELEY WHICH I
KNOW IS GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS CITY COUNCIL
[INAUDIBLE]
HOME.
THE REPORT MENTIONED NURSE
DELEGATION.
A NURSE TELEVISION IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO HEAR RP.
CALIFORNIA I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
BOTH HUMAN HOA KELLEHER ARP AND
SCANNED PUTS OUT SOMETHING
CALLED THE LTFS SCORECARD.
A NURSE DEL ADDITION CALIFORNIA
RANKS.
FORTY FOR BECAUSE IN CALIFORNIA
NURSES CAN ONLY DELEGATE TO OF
SIXTEEN MEDICAL TASK TO A PAID.
HOME CARE WORKER.
AND THAT MEANS THAT FOR EXAMPLE
I'M PAYING A HOME CARE WORKER.
SO I CAN GO TO WORK OR I CAN WE
TO WORK PART TIME.
BUT I MIGHT HAVE TO HAS A
CAREGIVER I MEAN YOU HAVE TO GO
HOME AND DO SOME OF THESE
MEDICAL TESTS AT HOME LIKE TO
FEEDING OR MEDICATION MANAGEMENT.
A WINDOW THAT WILL REQUIRE
STRONG LEADERSHIP IN THE
LEGISLATURE HUAMBO WERE REALLY
HOPING A FEW DOT COM COME TO BE.
FINALLY TELEHEALTH AND I'M JUST
HIGHLIGHTING SOME WE SUPPORT ALL
[INAUDIBLE]
TELEHEALTH.
ROM TELEHEALTH IS REAL IMPORTANT
A. R. P. ALSO RECEIVED IS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL TO HELP FAMILY
CAREGIVERS AND THERE ARE
RECENTLY RELEASED AARP PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE REPORT.
ON TELL HEALTH AND FAMILY
CAREGIVERS IS ACTUALLY IN YOUR
PACKET.
ALL JUST YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE CENTER FOR HELP
CONNECTED HEALTH POLICIES.
ELECTRONIC CONSOLES WORKGROUP.
AND JUSTICE YOUR RE SIGNED ON TO
A COALITION LETTER. TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SO THIS WOULD BE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE CHANGE.
ARM ASKING A TO EXPAND EXISTING
MEDI CAL FUNDED HEALTH
TELEHEALTH SERVICES TO INCLUDE
ANY CONSOLE SERVICES FOR ALL
SPECIALTIES.
SO AS IT MOVES FORWARD WE WILL
MAKE SURE TO KEEP.
EVERYONE A PRIZE WHERE THAT IS
SO AGAIN I THANK YOU FOR HAVING
US HERE AND LOOK FORWARD.
TO WORKING TOGETHER FOR MANY
YEARS TO COME.
THANK YOU WELL LET'S HAVE A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE FOR ALL OF OUR
RESPONDENTS HERE.
SHE IT'S EXCITING TO HAVE SUCH A
GREAT TEAM OF FOLKS THAT.
OF ARE EXCITED ABOUT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WHILE PUSH
SUPPORT HAVE OTHER SUGGESTIONS
OF WHAT WE CAN DO.
AND SO ABA RIGHT NOW WE SORT OF
UNITS BINDS WE BROKE GOOD AND
BRAVE LITTLE BIT BEHIND.
OTHER RECEPTIONS FOLLOWING ARM
THIS HEARING AND SOLID TAKE THE
NEXT FIFTEEN MINUTES OR SO.
I TO SEE THERE IS ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT HOLD EVERYBODY TO TO TWO
MINUTES AND I'LL POLITELY CUT
YOU OFF AROUND TWO MINUTES
INDIGENOUS TIME ASIDE WHAT HAS
OPPORTUNITY. TO SAY A FEW WORDS
OF THE LIKE.
TO I DON'T KNOW A COUPLE PEOPLE
WITH MY CLIENTS YEAH I'VE BEEN A
MICROPHONE HERE.
DANIELLE'S PERFECT.
FIRST OF ALL I APPLAUD THE
COMMISSION FOR THE WORK DONE.
THANK YOU.
ALSO I THANK GOD ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COME LAGER JOBS OFFICE FOR
INVITING ME.
I'M SOMEWHAT COMICAL STORM GOING
TO SAY I HAVE A SOLUTION. FOR
ALL OF IT.
BECAUSE EVERYTHING THAT I'M
HEARING SOME WHAT COMES DOWN TO
ECONOMICS.
THE PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE MONEY
TO PAY A CARE GIVER.
BOB THE PEOPLE THE THE WORKERS
NOT GETTING ENOUGH MONEY.
THE THE THE MEASURES THAT WE
NEED TO PUT THROUGH.
AND WE NEED THE FUNDS FOR IT.
I'VE BEEN A CAREGIVER FULL TIME.
FOR MY DAD AND THEN MY MOTHER
EXCUSE ME AND I ACT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED BE A FREELANCE
JOURNALIST.
IT TOOK A LOT OF TIME MONEY.
BUT WHAT HAPPENED A NIGHTMARE
OCCURRED WHEN MY MOTHER STOPPED
WORKING.
AND A FAMILY MEMBER GOT.
WHO WAS THE FIRST ON THE ADVANCE
MEDICAL DIRECTIVE FELT SHE
NEEDED TO BE IN A HOME?
FIRST OF ALL NOT ANY SLUR
TOWARDS MS STILL.
SHE HADN'T IHS ES WORKER THAT I
GOT TO HELP ME.
BUT THERE WERE CERTAINLY ISSUES.
MAYBE BECAUSE THE PERSON WASN'T
BEING PAID ENOUGH BUT THE PERSON
WAS NOT ADEQUATE IN MANY WAYS
THERE WERE THAPSUS.
THERE WERE LIES TOLD SHE WAS
GIVING MY MOTHER DOUGHNUTS FOR
BREAKFAST.
INSTEAD OF OUR MIX MAKING HER A
MAIL I HAPPEN TO HEAR THAT WHEN
MY MOTHER DIDN'T HANG UP THE
PHONE WELL.
SO MY MOTHER ENDED UP IN A
NURSING FACILITY [INAUDIBLE]
AND I CONTACTED ASSEMBLY COME
LOCKER JOB ABOUT THIS IT'S A
NIGHTMARE AND I WAS THE FORMER
VOLUNTEER ON BOSMAN. FOR SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES IN THE
NINETIES SO I HAD SOME IDEA OF
THE PROCESS AND WHAT GOES ON NOW.
THIS IS WHERE THE MONEY CAN COME
FROM.
THE COUNT THE STATE CONTRACTS
WITH.
COUNTY DISTRICT OFFICES THEY ARE
NOT DOING THEIR JOB.
THEY ARE DOING WITH CALL
LICENSING AND CERTIFICATION FOR
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES.
I HAVE A PACKET IN THIS IS ONLY
PART OF THE DEFICIENCIES FROM
LAST YEAR IN THIS YEAR.
JUST THIS YEAR ALONE THIS
FACILITY HAS BEEN CITED.
BOB FOR THIRTY FIVE DEFICIENCIES
AND SEVEN CITATIONS.
WITH CITATIONS HIT THEM A BIT
HARDER BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO PAY
THE FEDERAL ITS FEDERAL I'M
SORRY ITS STATE AND THEY HAVE TO
PAY A FINE.
THE DEFICIENCIES ARE JOKE.
ALL THESE NURSING FACILITIES DO
OUR PLC'S PLANETS PLANS OF
CORRECTIONS.
AND THEY'RE NEVER IMPLEMENTED
CEMENT IT I WANNA.
RESPOND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IMAGE
THE TIME OF WRITING BY OKAY BUT
I'M ABOUT ONE INCH SOMETHING
BECAUSE I HAD A BILL THAT I'M
WORKING ON THIS YEAR THAT MAP
THAT.
IT WE MAY HAVE TO START AGAIN
NEXT YEAR THE HOUSE TO DO WITH
THE THE A WITH WITH CITATIONS
FOR DOES A NURSING HOMES BUT I
ALSO WANT TO MENTION THAT AS WE
CONTINUE THIS INFORMATION
HEARINGS.
MY PLAN IS FOR ONE OF THE NEXT
INFORMATION.
WE ON SKILLED NURSING BRIAN HE'S
ACTIVELY BECAUSE THE REPORT THAT
CAME OUT REGARDING SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES THANKS SO I'M
WILL MAKE SURE TO MAKE SURE THAT
TO OUR SON THE MEMBER WILL MAKE
SURE THAT.
YOU KNOW ABOUT WHEN THAT HEARING
IS A MAY NOT BE HERE AS IDEAS
HOURS A. OKAY COULD IT'LL IT'LL
LIKELY BE LIVE.
A STRAIGHT AS SHE MIGHT AS WELL
ARE LOOKING AT THERE YEAH JUST
TO SOME BUT NOW.
JUST SOME THIS UP TONS OF MONEY
IS BEING WASTED BY THE STATE.
PAYING THESE COUNTY DISTRICT
OFFICES TO DO A JOB AND THEY'RE
PAID QUITE WELL IN THE JOB IS
NOT BEING PERFORMED SO THE STATE
CAN TAKE IT BACK IN WITH THOSE
FUNDS.
DO SOME OF THE SERVICES THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS FOUND THAT WILL
HELP US ALL ARE ARE THEY HERE
GIVERS YEAH THANK YOU SO MUCH I
AM HOPING THAT THAT INFORMATION
HE WILL EXPOSE SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT ARE GOING ON BUT I'M
JUST TALKING OUT OF SORTS IF I
CAN.
BEAT MY AND THAT SOUNDS LIKE A
THANK YOU FRAZIER.
GENTLEMAN HERE IN THIS PLACE.
IN HER MUCH.
I AM SO MUCH PUSHY ON HERE
REPRESENTING THAT COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
AGING COMMUNITY SERVICES.
SOMEBODY MENTIONED ABOUT THE THE
AREA AGENCY ON AGING. THIRTY
THREE AGENCIES AND ONE OF THE
AGENCIES IS WITHIN THE COUNTY
AND I WORK FOR THAT AGENCY.
SO FAMILY CAREGIVER SUPPORT
PROGRAM IS A VERY IMPORTANT
PROGRAM.
THAT WE'RE STRIVING. TO MANAGE
AND PROVIDE SERVICES IN SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN THE LAST FISCAL YEAR
WE WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE.
UP TO TWO THOUSAND SERVICES TO
TWO THOUSAND CLANS.
YOU COMPARE THAT WITH THE HUGE
DEMAND THAT'S JUST NOTHING.
AND THE LIFE STORIES PERSONALITY
STORIES PRESENTED TODAY.
THERE ARE SO MANY SIMILAR AND
EVEN WORSE.
STORIES THAT WE HEAR.
UP WE IS IN THE HOMES MANY HOMES.
DOCTOR WEBER MENTIONED ABOUT
REPORTS OF BEING SUBMITTED TO
FPS EPISODE REPORTS [INAUDIBLE]
THRAWN.
PEOPLE WHO OBSERVE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD ABOUT.
THOSE WHO COULDN'T GIVE FAMILY
CAN GIVE US SUPPORT IN THAT
NEGLECTED OR ISOLATED.
AND THEY END THEIR LIFE THERE
WITHOUT ANYBODY CLOSE BY AROUND
THEM.
AND SO THE CONCERN IS REALLY
THERE AND I'M HAPPY TODAY.
WHAT I'M UNDERSTANDING IS ALL
THIS REPORT THEM FOR MISSION?
PUT TOGETHER IN THIS.
FANTASTIC THREE REPORT
[INAUDIBLE]
SIMPLY SPEAKS TWO VOLUME OF
CONCERNS.
AND THE COUP COMMITMENT THAT WE
CAN ALL SHARE [INAUDIBLE]
TOWARDS IMPROVING.
THE FAMILY CAREGIVER SUPPORT
PROGRAM I JUST WANTED TO ADD
THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON.
IT AFTERNOON MONEYNESS GLENNA
WILSON.
AND I APPRECIATE THE PANEL AND
THEIR PRESENTATION I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE OUR ELECTED OFFICIALS.
MY POINT IS THAT I AM A
REGISTERED NURSE.
AND I HAD TO TAKE CARE OF MY
FATHER WHO HAD DEMENTIA NOW.
IF I HAD NOT HAD A MEDICAL
BACKGROUND.
I COULD NOT HAVE COMMUNICATED
WITH THE MEDICAL TEAM.
A WHAT WAS EXPECTED I WOULD NOT
KNOW THE QUESTIONS TO ASK.
AND THERE WERE SOME THINGS THAT
WERE SUGGESTED THAT I DID NOT
AGREE WITH BECAUSE I KNOW
PATIENTS RIGHTS I KNOW QUALITY
OF CARE AND I KNOW QUALITY OF
LIFE.
GETTING BACK TO YOU I RETYPE
THEM FROM THAT AGENCY HOME A
HEALTH FACILITY INSPECTION
DIVISION.
AND I WAS ONE OF THOSE SURVEYORS
IS THAT WHEN THEY SAW ME COMING
THEY KNOW THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
TERMINATED.
SO OFTEN TIMES SURVEYOR WILL NOT
WRITE THE DEFICIENCIES BECAUSE
THEY'RE GETTING MONEY UP ON THE
TABLE THAT'S ALL I'M
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT WHEN
THEY HAVE THE GOLD IS NOT TWO
MINUTES WHEN THEY GO TO A
CONVALESCENT HOME YEAH YEAH.
YOU GO TO A CONVALESCENT HOME
THEY WILL TAKE THE PERSON IS
PENSION EXCEPT THIRTY FIVE
DOLLARS OKAY NOW WE DON'T KNOW
WHEN THAT LAW TOOK EFFECT I
CALLED.
A ASSEMBLYMAN DOVE OFFICE ABOUT
THAT SO THE PERSON I TALKED TO
AT A CONVALESCENT HOMES IS I'VE
BEEN WORKING HERE TWENTY FIVE
YEARS IT HAS BEEN THAT FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS TO SORT ALL
THIS GOING TO CHANGE.
THANK YOU OKAY SO THAT THE LADY
WITH THE MICROPHONE THAT THE
LADY IN FRONT THE GENTLEMAN
THERE THE LADY IN THE BACK AND
THOSE FOR THE NEXT.
FOUR THANK YOU I'M DOCTOR TO
ROMERO'S AND I'M A RETIRED
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROFESSOR OF
THIRTY EIGHT YEARS.
AND BECAUSE I'M ALSO A FORMER
MEMBER OF CGA I WOULD LIKE TO
TALK TO IS SPECIFICALLY TO IS HE
AYE YOU AND AND THE OTHER
ORGANIZATION BECAUSE ONE THING
THAT IS LACKING HERE.
IS A QUESTION OF CERTIFICATION.
THIS IS THE REASON WHY THEY ARE
NOT CONSIDERED PROFESSIONAL WHAT
WE NEED TO DO IS TO INCLUDE IT
IN THE HOUSE.
OF PROGRAM OF EDUCATION.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CERTIFYING THAT
ANYONE WHO IS A HEALTH CARE
GIVER IS CERTIFIED TO BE A
PROFESSIONAL OR SEMI
PROFESSIONAL.
THIS WILL TAKE CARE OF THE
MINIMUM WAGE IT ALSO WILL
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF THE HOME
CARE AND NUMBER.
THREE AS TO THE FEDERAL PROGRAM
LET ME SAY IT SHOULD BE A PART
OF SOCIAL SECURITY.
A PART OF MEDICARE.
THAT IT SHOULD BE A HEALTH
CONCERN THAT MEET ALL THE NEEDS
OF ALL AMERICANS AND IF WE DID
NOT HAVE TO DOUBLE DEALING WHERE.
TEACHERS ARE NOT PERMITTED TO BE
IS SOCIAL SECURITY BECAUSE I DID
NOT RECEIVE IT.
IF IT WAS ALL OPEN AS AN OPTION.
IT WOULD ALSO INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY.
THAT WOULD BE PERMITTED AND
PROVIDE. FOR ALL SERVICE SAYS
NEEDED UP BECAUSE THE UNITED
STATES SO THEREFORE WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THE REVAMPING OF HEALTH
CARE.
THE HEALTH INDUSTRY AND THE
INCLUSION.
OF HOME CARE.
DEALERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU [INAUDIBLE]
THANK DR.
BITING ME TODAY I HAVE BEEN A
CLOSE HER PROGRAM TWELVE YEARS.
OKAY OF MOTHER FATHER AND AND
AND WITHOUT THAT PROGRAM.
WE COULD NOT HAVE DONE IT AND
ALL OF THE ISSUES THAT HAVE COME
UP THE FINANCIAL EVERYTHING ELSE
WE ARE DEALING WITH NOW AS WE
ARE ON SOCIAL SECURITY BUT
LOOKING AT WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN TO US.
AND WE'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT
PROGRAMS LIKE THE CRC ARE FULLY
FUNDED I RUN A SUPPORT GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THEM TO SAY THANK YOU.
AND I'M SPEAKING FOR THE PEOPLE
IN MY GROUP WHO COULDN'T COME
TODAY THAT ARE PLEADING PLEASE
MAKE SURE THAT THESE PROGRAMS
DON'T GO DOWN BUT UP.
I HAVE ONE LADY NOW THAT THOUGHT
THEY THOUGHT SHE WAS HAVING A
STROKE OVER THE WEEKEND BECAUSE
OF THE STRESS AND THIS.
AND THIS CANNOT CONTINUE BECAUSE
THEN THOSE OF US WHO THE CARE
GIVERS.
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IF WE GO
DOWN [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
ARE THOSE VERY TIMELY BECAUSE I
JUST WANNA GO AHEAD AN ECHO SOME
OF THOSE THOUGHTS MY NAME'S JACK
LIED IN THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
THE FAMILY CAREGIVER RESOURCE
CENTER IN ORANGE COUNTY.
AND I WANTED TO JUST SHARE SOME
OF MY EXPERIENCES ARE BUT MOST
NOTABLY I WANTED TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF OF THE MILLENNIAL
CAREGIVERS AND YOUNGER CARE
GIVERS.
A LOT OF THE PEOPLE WE'RE SEEING
IN OUR OFFICES WORK.
THEY'RE NOT LOOKING AT BROAD
POLICY DECISIONS THAT YOU VOTE
BUT THEY DO WANT TO UNDERSTAND
WHY THEY CAN'T SPEND THEIR
FLEXIBLE SAVINGS ACCOUNT. TO PAY
FOR SOME OF THE HOME CARE FOR
THEIR LOVED ONES THEY WANT TO
ASK.
THEY DON'T THAT THE ONLY PERSON
DOESN'T ASK ABOUT WHAT MEDICARE
IS OUR DOESN'T MEDICARE PAY FOR
THAT.
BUT THE QUESTION WAS SAID DOES
MEDICARE PAY FOR THAT.
THE SIX MILLENNIAL THAT I
PROVIDED THERE BECAUSE I'M A
CLINICAL THERAPIST BY TRADE
[INAUDIBLE]
I DO THERAPY FOR OUR CENTER.
OF MILLIONS COME IN THERE EVEN
THOUGH THAT MEDICARE EVEN EXISTS.
BUT THEY'RE DROPPING OUT OF
SCHOOL.
THEY'RE PROVIDING CARE AND WHAT
THEY'RE LEARNING AND WHAT OUR
WORKING FOLK.
WORKING CAREGIVERS ARE LURKING
LEARNING IS THAT THERE IS
SOMETHING WRONG WITH OUR LONG
TERM CARE SYSTEM.
THEY CAN'T PIECE IT TOGETHER
IT'S FRAGMENTED AND EVEN THOUGH
THEY'RE EDUCATED WORKING.
I CANNOT FIND A WAY TO GET THEIR
LOVED ONE THE CARE THEY THINK
THEY NEED.
AND YES THEY ARE.
AT WORK BUT THEY'RE REALLY NOT
AND THAT'S THAT SUB.
A IT'S NOT A BENEFIT TO THEIR
EMPLOYER AND LASTING UNLIKE
SAY'S IS ON THE TASK FORCE OF
THE COMPUTER GOES FORWARD I
THINK WOULD LIKE TO INCLUDE SOME
SOME -- I'D
LIKE TO SEE SOME REPRESENTATION
FROM.
EMPLOYERS LARGE EMPLOYERS
BECAUSE I DO A LOT OF LUNCH AND
LEARNS AND THEY ARE ALWAYS FULL
AND AND AND EMPLOYERS ARE OUT
THERE AND THEY WANT TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE TOO MUCH LIKE THE
THEY'VE ADDRESSED THE ISSUE OF
CHILDCARE.
THEY WANT THEIR THEY DON'T WANT
TURN OVER THEY WANT THEIR
EMPLOYEES HAPPY AND ENGAGED TO
WORK [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
THE VERY VERY BACK.
HI MY NAME IS NADIA TORONTO AND
I JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF A LOW LIFE AND GETTING
EMOTIONAL.
SOME TRIED.
TO COMPOSE MYSELF I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT I AM A LAY PERSON AND I
USED TO WORK FOR A FORTUNE FIVE
HUNDRED COMPANIES --
AS A BANKER.
WHICH I HAD TO RETIRE EARLY
BECAUSE I DID HAVE ACCESS TO
FAMILY MIL OF FAMILY LEAVE
[INAUDIBLE]
BUT IT JUST GOT TOO INVOLVED
BECAUSE AS MY PARENTS AGE OF
FORCING MY FATHER PASSED OF
DEMENTIA.
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE AND MY
MOTHER WHO'S NINETY FOUR VERY
LUCID [INAUDIBLE]
AND DOWN.
BUT SHE IS DISMISSED BUT BECAUSE
THE CARE HAS EVOLVED I HAD TO
RETIRE EARLY.
I AM VERY GRATEFUL FOR U. S. C.
WILL --
INDUCTED --
FIT TEN I MET HER JUST RECENTLY
AND I HAVE THE COOK CALM THE
SUPPORT GROUP AT TRAIN WITH.
OF MISS BOBBI BIT OF MISS BOBBI.
BUT I JUST WANT IS SAYING.
WHATEVER I CAN DO TO HELP.
WITH GETTING THIS.
MUCH NEEDED INDUSTRY ON TRACK.
WE ALL KNEW THAT THE BABY
BOOMERS WERE AGING I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY WE WERE BETTER
PREPARED BUT WE CAN'T GO
BACKWARDS.
BUT WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO DO IS
PARTICIPATE AS A LAY PERSON
WHATEVER I CAN DO I AM WITH YOU.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
THERE'S GENERAL.
PLACES WHERE I BELIEVE PROFIT IS
MORE IMPORTANT THAN PEOPLE --
I HAVE BEEN.
INVOLVED AND TRIED TO GET THE
OMBUDSMAN TO COME OUT.
TO A FACILITY FACILITY THAT WAS.
DEFICIENT MI JUST THAT MY
OBSERVATION TRIED TO GET THE
OMBUDSMAN'S OUT HE'S OVERWORKED
DEPENDING ON THE LEVEL.
OF SEVERITY HE HAD TO GO TO
OTHER --
CLIENTS A HE JUST TOLD ME OUT
RIGHT THAT HE WAS JUST
OVERWORKED THERE WEREN'T ENOUGH
PEOPLE IN THE INDUSTRY TO
OVERSEE.
COME TO FIND OUT THE FACILITY
THAT MY MOTHER WAS AND WAS NOT
EVEN APPROVED [INAUDIBLE]
HEALTH AND THE PERSON THAT OWNED
THE FACILITY GOT IT THROUGH
BANKRUPTCY.
AND IT WASN'T EVEN AUTHORIZED
AND THIS PERSON.
IS GETTING A LOT OF HIS
FACILITIES.
I'M TRYING TO REMEMBER THE
DELEON [INAUDIBLE]
VERBIAGE.
THE CERTIFIED I BELIEVE THEY'RE
TAKING THE FACILITIES AWAY FROM
HIM BECAUSE OF DEFICIENCIES THAT
WERE.
GIVEN TO HIM AND HE HAS NOT
ACTED UPON IT.
SO YOU KNOW IT'S JUST A MATTER
OF PUT PUTTING THE PEOPLE FIRST
MAYBE HAVING TO SOCIALIZE.
AND I KNOW WITH US WAS TUGWELL
SOCIALISM BUT A SOCIALISTIC
DEMAGOGUE DEMOCRACY BUT
SOMETHING HAS TO HAPPEN.
WHERE?
PEOPLE COME FIRST BEFORE
PRACTICE [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH --
AND YES I WAS HEAD OF THE MIDDLE
THERE -- FOR
SHE WAS OF YOUR CARE CAREGIVER
FOR MY GRANDPARENTS --
NOW'S A CAREGIVER FOR MY FATHER
I'M I'M A STUDENT AT JOHNS
HOPKINS UNIVERSITY AND THIS IS A
GREAT CONVERSATION --
I WANTED TO ASK IS THERE BEEN
ANY CONSIDERATIONS TAKEN --
INTO TAPPING INTO THE STUDENT
DEBT.
SO I AM SO IF WE CAN FINANCIALLY
TAP INTO THE STUDENT DEBT AND
HAVE IT COULD BE RECYCLED BACK
INTO THE STATE.
I THINK THAT'S DEFINITELY
SOMETHING TO CONSIDER BECAUSE
THERE'S A FINANCIAL BURDEN --
WITH CAREGIVING AND AS LONG.
DO NOT TAKE --
MAJOR SUCH AS HEALTHCARE INTO
ACCOUNT SO IF THAT'S POSSIBLE
CONSIDERATION THAT'S SOMETHING I
THINK RHODE ISLAND AND ARM I
LIVE IN MARYLAND NOW I'M
ORIGINALLY FROM CALIFORNIA BUT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT --
THEY HAVE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION ESPECIALLY AS
TEACHERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE SUGGESTION.
OKAY COME ANYONE ELSE'S GOOD
WILL TAKE THESE LAST TWO K..
SO BURDEN LITTLEJOHN THE SIDE.
ARE THE ORDER.
AREA.
THANK YOU I REALLY ENJOYED A
HEARING ON THE INFORMATION THAT
THEY ARE.
NOT KNOWN ABOUT THIS COMMITTEE
UNTIL JUST YESTERDAY I WAS AT A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COME LATER DUBS --
OPEN HOUSE BUT I'M I'M A
FINANCIAL PLANNER AND I EDUCATE
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE ABOUT LONG
TERM CARE PLANNING BECAUSE IT'S
ONE OF THE BIGGEST PITFALLS --
IN DOING A RETIREMENT PLAN.
AND LOT OF PEOPLE AS THE PANEL
BEEPED OR SAYING.
DON'T REALIZE THAT IT'S NOT
COVERED BY THEIR MEDICAL
INSURANCE IS NOT COVERED BY
MEDICARE.
AND THE ONLY WAY THAT THEY HAVE
A SAFETY NET IS WHAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FOR A CALIFORNIAN.
AND THIS IS A HUGE TICKING
FINANCIAL FISCAL TIME BOMB.
AND LOT OF PEOPLE REALIZE IT BUT
I AS ONE OF THE OTHER PANEL
MEMBERS MENTIONED --
ONLY ABOUT FIVE OR 6% OF PEOPLE
IN THE COUNTRY HAVE LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE.
SO THAT MEANS 95% OF THE PEOPLE
THAT DON'T HAVE INSURANCE AND
DON'T HAVE ASSETS.
ARE GONNA END UP ON SOME KIND
THE STATE ASSISTANCE THERE'S NO
WAY THE STATE CAN AFFORD THAT
[INAUDIBLE]
SO.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH WE CAN DO
FOR PEOPLE RIGHT NOW OBVIOUSLY
THESE ARE PEOPLE HERE THAT I DO
SOME GREAT THINGS I BELIEVE.
BUT WE CAN LOOK AT THE NEXT WAVE
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE COMING WE ARE
THAT WAVE OF PEOPLE. TWENTY
YEARS FROM NOW THIRTY YEARS FROM
NOW IN EL OUR CHILDREN
GRANDCHILDREN TO BE TALKING
ABOUT US.
AND HOW TAKE CARE OF US SO WHAT
I TRY TO DO IS EDUCATE PEOPLE ON
WHAT CAN YOU DO NOW IF YOU HAVE
THE MEANS.
OF PLANNING NOW IT DOESN'T MEAN
YOU HAVE TO BUY INSURANCE BUT
YOU GOT TO HAVE SOME KIND OF
PLAN.
SO I ALWAYS TALK TO PEOPLE BY
HAVING SOME TYPE OF THE PLANETS
NOT ALL MY KIDS GONNA TAKE YOUR
ME ON MY DAUGHTER'S GONNA TAKE
CARE BECAUSE THAT MAY OR MAY NOT
BE THE CASE.
THAT'S NOT YOUR PLAN AND SO ON
IF THERE'S ANYTHING I CAN DO TO
HELP WITH THIS COMMITTEE LIKE I
SAID I DO TALK TO DO WORKSHOPS.
AND HELP EDUCATE PEOPLE ABOUT
PLANNING FOR LONG TERM CANNOT BE
HAPPY TO BE PART OF THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND THEN I'VE
OF FINAL THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
I THANKS SO MUCH --
FOR THIS PANEL AND I WANTED TO
ALSO THINK I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA FOR PASSING --
BILL I'M THAT ARE ORGAN I
REPRESENT THE YOUTH MOVEMENT
AGAINST ALZHEIMER'S I'M JUST
WANTED TO BRING UP --
YOUNGER FAST THAT IN PERSPECTIVE
TO THIS ENTIRE DISCUSSION --
WITCHES DOT ARM AS A YOUNGER
GENERATION I KNOW I'M MILLENNIAL
CAREGIVING WAS TOUCHED UPON IS
KIND OF A HOT TOPIC ON BUT THE
MILLENNIALS WHO AREN'T CARING
AND WHO AREN'T CARE GIVERS.
ARE VERY SOCIALLY CONSCIOUS AND
WE'RE STARTING TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS IS I'M A HUGE ISSUE
THAT IF WE DON'T ADDRESS IS
GOING TO FINANCIALLY BANKRUPT
THE ENTIRE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM --
NO MATTER WHAT DISEASE THAT YOU
COME DOWN WITH I'M AND SO WHAT
OUR ORGANIZATION PROPOSED I'M IS
THE CREATION OF A CARE COR --
SIMILAR TO YOUR TEACH FOR
AMERICA OUR PEACE CORPS OR
AMERICORPS --
BUT ADDRESSING --
AN ISSUE OF THIS TIME OF I'M THE
NEW CENTURY I'M AND SO I THINK A
LOT OF THE MEMBERS HERE WHO ARE
HERE WHO HAVE I'M BEEN VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF OUR EFFORTS.
I'M AND HAVE AYE BROUGHT US OFF
FOURTH I'M IN PASSING THIS
LEGISLATION AND IF ANY OF YOU
HERE ARE EITHER MILLENNIALS OR
REPRESENT ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN BRINGING IN A NEW
LEVEL OF VOTERS. TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE I'M THAT ARE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BUT ARE VERY SOCIALLY
CONSCIOUS I'D LOVE TO TALK WITH
YOU I'M [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU --
THE YOUTH MOVEMENT AGAINST
ALZHEIMER'S [INAUDIBLE]
THE BUT THEN THAT'S A VERY
ENCOURAGING HOPEFUL WAY --
TO END OUR PUBLIC COMMENT AND AT
THE BEFORE IMMEDIATE AGAIN WE
HAVE A RECEPTION STARTING UP IN
A COUPLE MINUTES.
ARE LIKE TO ASK MY COLLEAGUE US
IMMERSIVE SYDNEY KAMLAGER-DOVE
UP TO SEE SHE HAS MEAN CLOSING
REMARKS --
THANK YOU I JUST WANNA SAY HOW
ALWAYS INFORMATIVE --
AND INSPIRING THESE KINDS OF
HEARINGS AND GATHERINGS ARE --
AND PARTICULARLY FOR THIS IS.
BECAUSE SO MANY OF THE STORIES
ARE REALLY INVOLVED AROUND
PEOPLE THAT WE LOVE.
AND TO SEE TRANSFORMATIONS A CAR.
AND TO SOMETIMES FEEL LIKE YOU
DON'T HAVE A COMPLETE HANDLE ON
IT.
CAN BE VERY DISTURBING.
AND WHEN YOU ALSO ATTACHED THE
FACT THAT YOU MAY FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE THE ONLY.
ONE INVOLVED IN THIS SCENARIO OR
EXPERIENCE OUR JOURNEY --
IT CAN BE EVEN MORE OVERWHELMING
SO I WANNA --
THANK THE PANELS FOR SHARING
THEIR S. TESTIMONIALS AND THEIR
INFORMATION I CERTAINLY WANT TO
THANK THE AUDIENCE FOR YOUR
TESTIMONIALS BECAUSE THERE'S
NOTHING MORE --
COMPELLING THAN HEARING FOLKS
TAKE THEM I CAN TELL YOU THEIR
STORY AND REMIND YOU ABOUT WHY
YOU WERE ELECTED. ONE OF THE
GREAT THINGS ABOUT JULY IN THE
FALL.
IS THAT WERE ABLE TO TAKE THESE
HEARINGS TO THE COMMUNITY
OFTENTIMES WERE ACTUALLY HAVING
THESE CONVERSATIONS IN
SACRAMENTO SO THE WOMAN IN THE
BACK WHO SAID ON YOU KNOW WHAT
CAN I DO WHEN.
I HAD TO THE GENTLEMEN HE SAID
ANYTHING TO HELP THE DOW GREAT
STARTING POINT IS COMING TO
THESE HEARINGS AND IN SHARING
THE INFORMATION.
THE STATE IS SUCH A NEW WANTS
COMPLICATED BLACK BOX FOR SO
MANY FOLKS YOU KNOW WHAT I'LL DO
UP THERE --
THEN YOU CAN SAY WELL WE COME
DOWN FROM TIME TO TIME AND
ACTUALLY ENGAGE OUR CONSTITUENTS
IN WHAT WE'RE DOING AND SHARE
THIS INFORMATION.
AND SHARE ABOUT THE LOOPHOLES
YOU KNOW OR THE GAPS.
AND THAT'S WHERE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AND INVOLVEMENT CAN
REALLY MAKE THE DIFFERENCE AND
THEN ALSO MAKE SURE THAT YOUR
STAYING CONNECTED TO YOUR
REPRESENTATIVES YOU KNOW WE'VE
JUST STARTED A SENIORS BOARD.
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE STAYING IN TOUCH
WITH ON THE FOLKS THAT OUR
ELDERLY IN THE DISTRICT BUT ALSO
THE FOLKS THAT LOVE AND CARE --
FOR SENIORS IN THE DISTRICT AND
FIND OUT WHAT YOUR
REPRESENTATIVE IS DOING IN THE
ROLE THAT YOU CAN PLAY IF THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT IS INTERESTING
TO YOU.
I'M SURE THAT SOME OF A CHAIRMAN
KALRA AS IDEAS FOR LEGISLATION
CAME FROM HIS DISTRICT.
THAT'S HOW IT SHOULD BE.
SO THANK YOU ALL AND I'M SURE I
LOOK FOR DISSING HOW DO YOU ON
THAT RECEPTION AND THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SAY THOSE WORDS
THANK YOU SYDNEY.
AYE AND A BOOK BEFORE I CLOSE
THIS ONE ALSO THINK FIRST OF ALL
THE JUNK I WRITE VERY BREWER.
IS OUR CHIEF CONSULTANT.
CONSULTANT FRANK YOU A LOT OF
GREAT WORTH.
DURING LAST YEAR AND A HALF.
ALSO I THINK MY OF THE COMMITTEE
[INAUDIBLE]
MYERS.
BECAUSE THE GOVERNMENT HAS.
SEE SHE IS RUNNING UP JUST TALK.
OF COURSE BECAUSE WORKING RIGHT --
BITE MY KILEY WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH I POSSIBLE AND SO DUMPING
ONE I THINK OF THE WHOLE USC
TEAM.
UP FOR MAKING IN THE SPRING
CREDIBLE THEN YOU --
HAPPENS THANK YOU I AND I JUST
WANNA.
THANK EVERYONE THAT SPOKE
EVERYONE THAT'S HERE BOTH ON THE
PANELS LAWS PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND ALL THE TASK FORCE MEMBERS
THAT -- HELP
WITH THIS REPORT TOGETHER I YOU
KNOW I'M A END BUT WHEN I
STARTED LAST YEAR I'VE LEARNED A
LOT AND I'VE SAID IT BEFORE AND
I'LL SAY IT AGAIN.
I'VE BEEN AT THIS NOW FOR YOUR
HOUSE MANY OF YOU'VE BEEN DOING
IT FOR MANY MANY YEARS.
BUT THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME.
OF THE PRIVILEGE OF JOINING YOU
IN IN THIS FIGHT IN THIS
MOVEMENT.
UP LAST YEAR OF MOOD THERE IS A
REASON WHY THE FERRY FIRST WE
HEARD ABOUT LONG TERM CARE FROM
A NUMBER OF FOLKS.
THE VERY FIRST IMPLEMENT
INFORMATION BEYOND SAN JOSE WAS
FOCUS ON LONG TERM LONG TERM
CARE.
AND JIM CARREY INSURANCE HOW WE
FINANCE THAT LONG TO GET
FINANCING SO UPMC DOES NOT GOING
ANYWHERE WE NEED TO FIGURE THAT
OUT AND SO I THINK THAT.
THIS REPORT ONCE AGAIN I THINK
WE ESTABLISHED IS WHAT WE
CONTINUE TO HEAR ARM AND IN OF
THESE OF AS SUDDEN A COLLEAGUE
SAID.
THESE HEARINGS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US --
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US FOR
BARRY AS WE THINK ABOUT THE NEXT.
YEAR LEGISLATIVE CYCLE OF A LOT
OF THE BILLS IN THE BUDGET ASKS --
INCLUDING FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE GOT FOR ELDERS
SPACING ABUSE AND PACING ALMOST
AS A THREE MILLION DOLLARS WAS
REFERRED.
TO UP FOR DATA TO HELP US ONE ON
THE I OCS US ISSUE.
I'M ALZHEIMER'S CHECKOFF I AND A
BILL RIGHT NOW THAT I WANT TO
MENTION THIS IS A LIVING WAIVER
BILL.
ARM WHICH AT THE MOMENT AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICE HAS CAUSED SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT.
SO WE REALLY NEED FOLKS DEVON
[INAUDIBLE]
LET THE YEAH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IS.
IT'S A FIVE YEAR PHASE IN THE
DEPARTMENTS ARE GOING TO BE HIT
WITH THAT ALL ONCE SO WE REALLY
NEVER EVOLVED A HANDS ON DECK.
BECAUSE THAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW ADDS UP BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
IN THE SENATE WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE WE GET THAT THE REAL DATA
[INAUDIBLE]
BASICALLY.
BOB INCREASED NUMBER S. LEADING
A WAIVER SLOTS DAISY ALMOST OF
THE FACTOR OF FIVE UNIT OVER
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND WE NEED THAT
DESPERATELY SO PLEASE.
IS MY ADVOCATE RHONA ON UP HAD
ON A PLEASE ADVOCATE FOR THIS IS
LEADING LABOR BILL.
THE BEST YOU CAN ARM AND AB TWO
TO THREE THREE TWENTY TWO THIRTY
THREE SO PLEASE A LOT OF THAT'S
FIGHT FOR THAT THOSE SLOTS --
THE FIRST TWO THOUSAND FIVE RD
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SO THAT
THE MEG THE NEXT GOVERNOR CAN
DEAL WITH THE REST.
BOB BUT I BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT THIS RIGHT HERE IS HEARING
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND LIKE
I DID THREE OF THEM LAST YEAR.
WE'RE ABLE TO DO AS A COMMITTEE
WE'RE GONNA DO MORE THAN THIS
YEAR MAY COME INTO THE FALL
RECESS.
ARE BUT I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
YOU THIS IS JULY RECESS AND SO
MANY FOLKS ON VACATION SO MANY
THOSE ARE THE THINGS TO DO WITH
THEIR FAMILY THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE ALL HERE.
CITY THE FACT THAT YOU'RE HERE I
MEAN SOME.
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE NEXT
HEARINGS IN THE FALL THE NEXT.
ONE QUITE POSSIBLY RABID
CONFIRMED IT WILL BE IN SAN JOSE
FOCUS ON SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES BECAUSE AS WE HEARD
FROM THE WOMAN EARLIER I'VE
HEARD FROM A NUMBER OF FOLKS.
ON ISSUES WE SAW THE REPORT THAT
CAME OUT ON SKILLED NURSING
THIRTIES BE MORE ACCOUNTABILITY
WAS OF THESE FACILITIES I THINK
WE NEED MORE INFORMATION REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT MEANS.
AND SO ON THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE OF THANK YOU FOR
HELPING TO EDUCATE US I LOOK
FORWARD TO CHATTING WITH SOME OF
YOU DURING THE RECEPTION SO
WHERE THAT THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.
HER